this is Jocko podcast number 148 with
echo Charles and me Jocko willing good
evening echo good evening 20 November
1950 dear mr. and mrs. Richardson I
regret that I must confirm my recent
telegram in which you were informed that
your son Master Sergeant William J
Richardson infantry has been reported
missing in action in Korea since 2
November 1950 I know that added distress
is caused by failure to receive any more
information or details therefore I wish
to assure you that at any time
additional information is received it
will be transmitted to you without delay
the term missing in action is used only
to indicate that the whereabouts or
status of an individual is not
immediately known it is not intended to
convey the impression that the case is
closed I wish to emphasize that every
effort is exerted continuously to clear
up the status of our personnel under
battle conditions this is a difficult
task as you must readily realize
experience has shown that many persons
reported missing in action are
subsequently reported as returned to
duty or being hospitalized for injuries
in order to relieve financial worry on
the part of the dependents of military
personnel being carried in a missing in
action status Congress enacted
legislation legislation which continues
the pay allowance and allotments of such
persons until their status is definitely
established permit me to extend to you
my heartfelt sympathy during this period
of uncertainty Sincerely Yours Edward F
Witsell Major General
US Army so obviously that is a letter
from the government about a missing
soldier this missing soldier in this
case is of William Richardson and
William Richardson or bill Richardson
who was a part of that whole melee that
unfolded in the beginning of the Korean
War when the Eighth Army was caught off
from the rest of coalition forces and
many of those that got caught off as
that retreat took place many Americans
and and South Koreans as well were
captured were killed or otherwise they
were somehow lost or missing and this
guy bill Richardson was one of those men
one of those men that went missing and
clearly from this letter his parents
were notified about that and he wrote a
book on these experiences that he went
through the book is called valleys of
death a memoir of the Korean War and he
actually has that letter from the army
to his parents inside the book which is
a pretty shocking thing to see and you
know these days they with with the
current way they notify they send people
to your house but I can't even imagine
that the old days when you just get a
telegram or a letter that shows up and
says that your your son's been missing
for three weeks or four weeks or
whatever the case may be but this book I
definitely there's the combat in this
book is out of hand and you're gonna see
that pretty quick and like every other
book that we review on here obviously I
can't read the whole thing but
definitely this book is worth getting
valleys of death a memoir of the Korean
War written by Colonel William or Bill
Richardson
and it's a phenomenal book so with that
let's dive right into it he lays out a
little bit of his perspective writing
the book here didn't they in the preface
of the book and here we go this is not a
history of the Korean War it is a down
and dirty look at some of the soldiers
who five years before had experienced
combat in the Second World War it is the
story of the men they would lead a new
generation of courageous young soldiers
in what would be the last true infantry
war the heroes of this story are the
young man of the 3rd battalion 8th
Cavalry Regiment and in particular the
men of the weapons platoon of L Company
most of them died the story is told
through my own eyes I have made a strong
attempt to avoid adding to the story
what others have said or what I have
learned over the last 57 years but there
are a few truths that are undeniable
Korea was a war that neither the country
nor the military was ready for and we
paid a high price for a lack of
readiness the disaster at Osan written
about in this book was caused by a lapse
of leadership from the highest echelon
down to the battalion level mistakes we
paid for with the blood of the most
heroic men I have ever known
and you know when we covered chesty
puller he talked a lot about that a lot
about the lack of readiness and if you
remember the marine corps throwing
together battalions to try and get over
there and that was the whole country
that was doing this and in the beginning
of this book it you know he talks about
he kind of introduces the characters
that he was with he talks about some of
the training that they had been through
he was part of a squad that fired the 57
they called it which is a recoilless
rifle the m18
it's a 57-millimeter recoilless rifle
okay it basically looks like a bazooka
kind of your traditional if you're in
your mind you picture the the bazooka
that's sort of what it looks like and
there's a bunch of different variations
of the bazooka and this is sort of one
of them and in this point when we pick
up the book he's kind of gone through
that and they actually are now heading
on Cal to California on their way to war
so you know he covers the kickoff of the
war and what that was like in him kind
of getting back in the game and here we
go they're heading to California to get
on a ship to go to Korea for the war
back to the book there was a gravity to
it we were on the doorstep of war we all
knew it and wanted to be disciplined
because when the bullet started
discipline could be the difference
between life and death that is indeed
true continuing the war in Korea had
reached a crisis level American and
South Korean units were fighting for
their lives
they'd been swept from the 38th parallel
and quickly forced out of Seoul the
North Korean swept south towards Pusan a
port on the eastern tip of the Korean
Peninsula now our troops were making
their last stand along the GNAT Tong
River in the West and and a line north
of the tegu reaching east to the Sea of
Japan and they were heading on the US
troop transport ship called the Pope
which had just been taken out of
mothballs if you don't know this they
take old old ships when they're not
needed they put them up well they put
them in a couple places around the
country but they put them up and they
called it mothballs and then they just
believed these big old ships sitting
there if they if they ever are needed
again they can pull them out and kind of
get them up to speed so that's what the
Pope was it was a vessel that was pulled
out of mothballs and now it was getting
ready to sail overseas and these guys
get on and the head overseas and then
back to the book after eight days Ambar
on board the ship word spread that we
were getting close to Japan we do
another month of training before landing
in
Korea we crowded along the rail looking
at the shore lights in the distance the
water made the lights from the city look
like stars its Yokohama and were headed
right for it I heard a soldier say
suddenly the ship started slowly turning
to the starboard and running south
parallel to the shore I didn't think
much of it but the next morning we were
informed that we were going straight to
Korea there you go that's the way the
military works sometimes you think
you're gonna go train for an extra month
and you have a little bit more time to
prepare for combat and all of a sudden
that time is gone and you're going
straight in straight into the combat
scenario so that's why everyone out
there in the military don't wait till
tomorrow to train it's not gonna come or
it may not come so they pull into this
port in Pusan back the book the smell
was unbearable the water around the dock
dock at Pusan was black and slick with
oil and sewage two docks up from where
we were was a cattle holding area with
and when they cleaned the Pens they just
hosed everything into the water the
pungent odor hit us as we approached the
pier most of the guys stayed below out
of the smell but I stayed on the deck
mesmerised by the port the Eighth Army
had established a perimeter to hold off
the Koreans people the Korean People's
Army until enough troops could arrive
and organize a counter-offensive set up
in August the perimeters western
boundary was formed mostly by the
knocked on River the North Koreans
crossed the NAT Tong River and then he
says I know one thing if you're
defending a river and the enemy is on
your side you're in trouble that evening
after another dinner of sea rations I
got the section together this is his his
little section of troops that he's
running he's in charge of I won't and
here's what he tells him I want everyone
to check his gear one more time
we're mu
moving to an assembly area north of the
tegu first thing in the morning and take
a moment to write home you never know
when you'll get another chance
and that's one of those things that that
can be pronounced a pretty heavy
statement when he's saying that and I'll
tell you when you're in that situation
if she's especially if you're young at
least in my situation if someone would
have told me that when I was 19 years
old I would have been fired up and
that's just the way it is yeah I guess
I'm some people think it's crazy to
think that way but I'm telling you
there's a whole group of human beings in
the world that they have a little
genetic makeup that makes them want to
go to war and so when you get told hey
you know write you write your last
letter home you're actually pretty fired
up about it again I know that sounds
completely crazy and even thing is he
was a little bit older so I think for
him he had had more gravity for him than
it did for his boys the other thing is I
think it's hard for them to have
recognized even though they read in the
news like how bad it was and we've heard
this from other people too we've heard
this from other people like you always
think it's not gonna be you right yeah
it's not gonna be me that gets that gets
killed it's not gonna mean that's not
gonna happen to me so you have that
little thing in your brain to where you
just think it won't happen to you so you
aren't that concerned about it and the
other thing is like you're you know you
just got done what we just got done with
World War 2 where all this heavy combat
and guess what we were back to back
World War champions right America was
back to back World War champion so how
are we gonna get into a worse situation
on this little random little Asian
country a little Peninsula like this
won't be a factor so you had to have
that in your head a little bit you had
to I don't think they recognized how
serious the situation was even though
they were saying it my point is that
even though you're getting told hey this
is a dire situation and we're holding up
a perimeter to try and wait for more
troops to arrive so we can actually do a
counter-offensive even though you hear
that
you're like alright that's no big deal
we'll handle it in my mind again I'm
trying I'm trying to transpose a
nineteen year old brain on this
situation yeah all right going back to
the book the trains to tag you left just
after noon I heard a few cheers as the
train picked up momentum so there you go
I'm right right the train is heading to
combat and what are the boys doing
they're cheering the train lumbering
down the track for a while and then
stopped at a siding word came back that
we were near the assembly area but had
to make way for a hospital train head
itself the train carrying the wounded
stopped for a few moments and we could
see the soldiers inside IV bags hung
next to litters men with bandaged arms
legs and heads lined the cars the few
walking wounded stared out the windows
the wounded Americans had dark
depressing eyes and a vacant stare a few
of our guys tried to pass them
cigarettes and candy from the window but
they didn't react they just stared into
space
so there's your reality check that's
what we're heading for and that's a
little wake-up call I doubt that the
there was cheers when the plane when the
train rolled north again and they go
from trains eventually they get off
trains and next up is that getting into
some troop transport trucks and here we
go back to the book as the trucks
rumbled forward we could see American
troops moving south down the road they
looked like ghosts frail with torn and
dirty uniforms their black eyes didn't
even register as we passed they had the
infantryman's thousand-yard stare
they were lost gone we were operating
under Lieutenant General Walton H
Walker's standing order to stand or die
Walker the Eighth Army commander had
issued the order in July before we'd
arrived and here's here's the quote from
from general Walker we are fighting a
battle against time there will be no
more retreating withdrawal or
readjustment of the lines or any other
term you choose there is no line behind
us to which we can retreat
there will be no Dunkirk there will be
no Bataan a retreat to Pusan would be
one of the greatest butcheries in
history we must fight until the end we
will fight as a team if some of us must
die we will die fighting together I want
everybody to understand we are going to
hold this line we are going to win now
that's it that's a heavy statement and
if you know a little bit of the
background about this Walker general
Walker was in World War one and World
War two and now he's in Korea and you
had MacArthur at the time who was in
Japan who was basically saying hey look
I don't care you're gonna hold one
you're gonna hold one
even though Walker was thinking hey I
need you know massive support I don't
know if we can pull this off and the
order came and he was like okay and you
know I I mean I talked about this if
you're getting that command you know you
can't come down and say well MacArthur
is telling us that we got it but I don't
think we can do it no he's like ok
that's what we're gonna do our best to
do now as you actually study what
unfolded eventually he held it as long
as he could and then he started to
tactically retreat to the best of his
ability and so he sort of compromised
he didn't just state it didn't stand
against Lauder
so he eventually made a more organ the
best organized retreat that he could but
still the the 8th army was on the run if
you remember this time this is when the
Marines were trying to hold the line as
well so it was a very hard situation
going back to the book thick black smoke
rose in a steady stream on the other
side of the horizon I could see only a
few of the squat huts but the valley and
ridges had thick scraggly bushes which
made it very difficult to see any
movement suddenly artillery shell
and mortar rounds crashed down around us
we dive into ditches that line the road
and waited for the barrage to end I
waved to my section and got them
together before we moved out toward the
outskirts of the village a smoky haze
with a pungent smell of gunpowder hung
over us as we started moving forward I
could feel my heart beating and my
breaths came quickly almost like I was
running but it wasn't nerves
it was adrenaline my body was on fire
popping with energy back on the road a
North Korean machine-gun to our right
opened fire I could see tracer rounds in
almost slow-motion dashing into the line
of men ahead of me the soldiers ducked
and dove out of the way as the rounds
bit into the dirt around them time is a
strange thing in combat sometimes it
moves so fast that you cannot believe it
and other times it is moving so slowly
that you could scream we drove into the
dirt and pressed ourselves flat against
the ground
Maccabi and Maccabee at this time as the
company commander started moving the
other platoons toward the guns while my
section part of the weapons platoon
provided supporting fire so there you go
they set up a little cover move this was
real combat all of my fears seemed so
far away now I didn't have time to worry
about how I'd react I just had to act
turning back towards Walsh's gun I
yelled for him to get in position and
start firing at the machine guns
Walsh nodded and started calling to his
men like veterans they ignored the
machine-gun fire and got the gun up and
got ready put some fire on that hill I
shouted pointing toward the North Korean
Gunners with my hand Walsh pointed out
the machine gun position and Gomez the
assistant gunner loaded around and halt
sighted in the gun and fired my section
fired its first shot of the war so a
couple key things that I liked about
this paragraph of the you know he talks
about time and the weird things that
time do does during combat and that
happens during any really stressful
situation where you become a hyper
sensitive to what's happening and in
with the way it appears the way it feels
is that time is actually slowing down I
think the first time that I ever
experienced that was in a
our crash not a bad car crash but I was
in a car crash and it seemed like things
were moving in slow motion and I wasn't
driving I was just a passenger but I was
that's the first time I ever felt it and
then the other thing I'd say you can you
can be expecting that be expecting if
you're going into combat that you might
have that slow motion and it's actually
a awesome thing because you can feel
like you can I don't know to me it
didn't feel like I was moving slow it
always felt like things were moving slow
and I could still it gave me more time
to react it's like if you're doing
jujitsu and your opponent was moving in
slow motion but even though you weren't
even though you couldn't move faster
than them you could see it and react to
it properly mm-hmm does that make sense
yeah and then the other thing is if you
notice the fear he's saying that he did
have time to be afraid which is
definitely something I felt where like
once rounds are being shot you're not
thinking oh I'm gonna get shot you're
thinking okay we need to we need to get
online we need appeal right we need to
we need to make a call as opposed to and
what is that that's based on in my
opinion is training and if you train
properly then you just react that just
that's just what happens and this is why
and you heard me say this at the at the
muster was talking about like from a
self defense perspective it's for
females that are doing jujitsu for the
first time I'm like hey if you've never
done jujitsu before you're about to see
that this is about as intimate as a
sport or or this about as intimate as an
activity you can possibly engage in
without actually taking it to the next
all right without actually having will
yes without being married to the other
person right so and and that's the thing
if you get used to that you get used to
somebody grinding on you get used to
someone grabbing you and you once you
get used to it then you don't have to
deal with that in the moment because you
are to not to deal with it you can just
react so it's the same thing here these
guys have trained really hard and so now
once this situation is unfolding what
they're doing is just reacting to it as
they should they're not sitting there
panicking and getting getting care not
that everyone's gonna be like that
because you will have some people that
will immediately get that that
fight-or-flight and they might roll into
the flight scenario of getting down and
hiding and so you might have to deal
with out a little bit
but be ready for any of those reactions
so now the first once they get through
this first big kind of firefight going
on now we're going back to the book the
guys were digging in I told them to set
up the guns but we'd be covering our
section with rifles that night we were
all wired after our first firefight and
it was good that we had something to do
I was happy to see that everyone knew
everybody was digging in with a sense of
urgency I was worried about our open
flank to the right
I ordered the section to dig in some
positions facing to the right in case we
had to occupy them when we were done I
told my guys to eat and rest while they
got with Walsh and grey word is the
North Koreans were attacking that night
so the most of the you'll see throughout
this book that the North Koreans and
then eventually the Chinese they do
their attacks during the night that's
what they do that's how they roll
they're there if you remember even T
Fred Harvey was talking about when he
was doing the island happy hopping
campaign they was Americans moving in
the day and then at night the Japanese
would attack so a similar situation here
now it's actually the opposite against
the enemy because we have you know we
have night vision capability so we have
a huge advantage at night so that's when
we normally work in and and and in the
SEAL Teams that's the way that's the way
we always worked we always worked at
night now when we got to Ramadi and it
was a lot of daytime fighting we had to
fight in the day but the preferred thing
is to fight at night and that's goes
back to the seals in Vietnam and if you
remember Roger Hayden I think it was
Roger Hayden was saying when they were
going out at night no one else was going
out at night it was just like seals
would go out at night but other than
that it was only the Vietcong that were
going out at night and the NVA whose but
friendly forces just just seals and I
know there's others there's other ones
but he was saying early on it was them
so now the attack comes here we go back
to the book the attack started with a
guttural scream the North Koreans came
out of the brush in waves we could see
them moving toward us like shadows
muzzle flashes exploded out of the
darkness there was very little aimed
fire instead
we were firing straight ahead and into
their assigned to zones soon screams
came from our wounded joined the chorus
of battle cries orders and machine guns
illuminating rounds from our mortar
section soon lit up the area like a
ballpark making the North Korean
soldiers look like silhouettes on a
firing range
we dropped several before the flare
burned out since the rounds were in
short supply the mortars waited several
minutes between rounds during a lull I
could hear one of the engineers to our
left screaming in pain and calling for
his mother his sobs and screams for help
landed harder than the North Korean
artillery shells finally private Jones
one of my young smart asses had heard
enough he started to yell and scream
I covered Walsh as he scrambled out to
Jones he was on the bottom of halls hole
crying Wallace tried to get him up but
he wouldn't move I climbed out and
helped Walsh dragged Jones's ass out of
the foxhole you stay with hall
I told Walsh snatching Jones by his
shirt-collar
I stumbled with him back to my foxhole
he crawled in and huddled against the
wall sobbing he couldn't talk even when
I asked him a simple question his body
heaved with every sob the engineer had
finally stopped screaming and now in an
ever desperate voice pleaded for someone
to come get him stay in your holes I
barked I was sure the North Koreans were
lying in wait hoping someone would try
and get him god I wished he would just
die that thought sent a jolt through me
Jesus Christ I didn't really mean that
that poor son of a [__]
my only thought now was please God bring
the daylight soon when the sun's rays
finally peeked over the horizon we
started getting the wounded off the hill
so there you go like I said there's some
people that are not gonna react well and
you got this kid Jones that can't handle
this situation and he's done he's done
what is this night - he's done and I
mean obviously it doesn't help when you
kind of one of your wounded guys out
just ahead of you and he's screaming for
help then crying for help and you can't
do anything and the order from
Richardson which is you know stay in
your halls and again this is the same
exact thing that T Fred Harvey talked
about when they captured one of his guys
and they the Japanese sat and tortured
him
it sounded like 3040 meters away they
tortured this guy the whole night and
the whole night T Fred Harvey's you know
leaders were saying stay in your home
stay in your holes were staying what if
what a what a nightmare that is back to
the book Walsh grabbed me and here's
what Walsh says Sarge
black lost it he's crying he's hugging a
tree and will not respond to me black I
didn't know him very well he was one of
the company's problem children he'd
gotten drunk after a unit picnic at Fort
Devens and the military police had
locked him up for being drunk and
disorderly this incident confirmed that
what I fought already black was going to
be a constant problem I put him in
Walsh's squad and we both kept on his
ass making sure he was doing the right
thing when I got to black he was wrapped
around a tree like a vine every time a
shell landed nearby he began shaking and
crying no talking was going to help I
just wanted to get him away from the
rest of the men the section had fought
well but after listening to the engineer
all night they had their own nerves to
contend contend with that made two men
within 24 hours if this continued I
would lose the whole section to fear
instead of the enemy
yeah
so two guys gone two guys can't any and
he ends up sending him to the rear cuz
he just can't you can't do anything with
this guy and that's a tough call to make
hey if I send this guy to the rear how's
that gonna affect everyone else on the
team have an all-time team is gonna be
thinking you know oh all I need to do is
cry and scream and I'll get I'll save my
ass hmm
so you know in my opinion there's just
if you're in these situations I think if
you're scared to die it's gonna be a
problem if you're scared to die it's
gonna be a problem if you basically
accept the fact that you you could die
and and you're okay with that that's how
you that's to me that's the difference
between these two guys and everyone else
everyone else was like okay do they want
to die no I'm not saying they want to
die but they recognize they can die and
they're okay with it you know maybe okay
was a strong word they accept it I
should say they accept it whereas these
two guys are scared and if you're scared
to die then I think this is this is the
kind of thing that happens because
obviously if you're if you're like okay
you know what there's a chance I could
die and that's the way it is and I'm
willing to take that chance so I'm gonna
do my best
like that's one attitude the other
attitude is I don't want to die and Here
I am in a situation where death is
everywhere around me and that just
closes in on your brain right that just
closes in on your brain I can't like I
can't imagine I can't imagine how that
would how that would affect you
psychologically if you are scared of the
scared of dying and again I don't want
to I'm not trying to sound like hey I
want to die or troops on the front line
are like yeah we don't care if we die no
I'm not talking about that but to be
able to psychologically say hey look I
could die that's one of the possible
outcomes here and okay I get it and I'm
okay with that
that's different than being I don't want
to die out if you don't if you're if
your main goal is to not die and you're
in a combat situation especially a
really really violent hardcore combat
situation like this this isn't gonna
work out good
you at all yeah because you it's like
when I you know when I used to work with
MMA fighters if they were scared of
getting knocked out yeah
if that's what they were scared of it's
really hard to not be to go into that
cage with any level of confidence
because you're scared of that one thing
that might happen it's the same thing
here if you're so scared of that one
thing happening that's gonna possess
your brain yeah and even you yeah mmm eh
even if like you're I don't know if
you're new to boxing or something you
know and you it's like you haven't
accepted the fact that you're gonna get
hit yeah so every time like someone even
flip you know if they throw a feint
you're reacting to everything right so
if you're constantly under the kind of
stress
yeah the stress of like bullets and all
this does it's like you're what didn't
we call your self preservation yeah
mechanism in your brain is just firing
firing firing and then after a while the
thing is just like gone haywire already
yeah it's gone into overdrive that's
what's happening to these guys man it's
horrible it's horrible to see all right
back to the book the smoke and dust
still hung in the air when they attacked
again
the first waves came with rifles behind
them more soldiers followed and picked
up the weapons left by the dead so
that's a that's a common battle plan
where we're gonna hear is then we've
heard it before in in other books about
the Korean War hey we're gonna send the
first wave they're gonna have rifles and
magazines the next wave is just gonna
come and pick up the dead guys gear and
use that so part of the plan is the guys
dying or the planning part of them is
absolutely part of the plan
and not a small amount either because
you know when you when when the military
when the US military when you plan a big
operation you plan for casualties and I
can't say this about the SEAL Teams the
SEAL Teams isn't like okay like we're
gonna take this amount of casualties the
SEAL Teams doesn't do that we're not
planning to take any cows days but like
you go with a big a big division going
in for an airborne drop in world war two
they were like okay 10% of these folks
are gonna be injured on the drop
that's it so yeah and these guys are
just saying hey we got whatever 300 guys
attacking we need about 70 guns or
whatever that number is back to the book
on almost every attack the North Koreans
tried to slip behind our lines and cut
off our avenue of retreat once they did
they would pound our flanks this time
the North Korean soldiers charged uphill
right into the teeth of our machine guns
after the third attempt they quit and we
settled in for a tense night we waited
all night but they didn't attack again
North Koreans instead went around us and
caught off the road back to Tabu dong as
the fingers of the pink light shot up
over the horizon we were ordered to
withdraw through the Korean line this
was not going to be easy so going back
so they're getting called back hey
there's a Korean line and they're
getting told to fall back pass that line
they got it they basically they're kind
of surrounded even at this point and
here we go he kind of expands on what it
was like from his perspective and he
talks a little bit about this just
general Walton Walker's mobile defense
which was hey basically use a thin line
of people to sort of sort of hold up the
enemy and then as like a screen and then
the bulk of the force would be ready for
a counter-attack and it was it was kind
of considered a theory at this time but
this is what they were trying to do and
then he says for us ground troops it was
confusing this game of chess had become
maddening I never had a map and seldom
knew the numbered designation of the
hills or objectives now that's crazy
that's freaking crazy and you've heard
me say this the most important piece of
information you can have on the
battlefield is where you are mmm if you
don't even have a map and he's a section
leader and doesn't have a map just FYI
like nowadays when we go out every
single guy has a detailed battle map of
the whole area of operations hmm to
think that you have a section Lee
that doesn't even have a map that's
that's crazy and then the number
designations he talks about when you
know you hear about Hill 348 or whatever
he doesn't even know what those are
back to the book we only knew to move
attack and defend unknown Hills that
would stop the North Koreans from
breaking through and capturing the city
of Teague this was our world following
orders fighting for one another being
successful and somehow surviving now
there they're sort of in a little lull
in the fighting and one of his guys
comes over the guys name is gray I'm not
feeling very good I need to sit down for
a few minutes Gray said his head was
pounding and he felt dizzy try to come
over as soon as you can
are you gonna be all right yeah just
give me a few minutes when we got to the
other side of the ridge I turned and
looked back at Grace sitting on a tree
stump he had his head in his hands now
we know we know what this is a symbol of
right this is symbol of like a little
bit of combat stress happening but he's
just trying to get it together mm-hmm
gray and Walsh had been great squad
leaders and I hope he was okay I needed
him to I needed him and his leadership I
had taken off my helmet to wait to wipe
away some sweat when gray and the stump
suddenly disappeared in a fireball an
artillery round landed right on him I
was stunned and just stood on the ridge
looking at the smoking crater something
happens to men who see combat no matter
how you try you cannot make death
invisible it is there with you every
moment that split second would be seared
into my mind for the rest of my life but
at that time we didn't have time to
mourn grey we had to get dug in start
digging that round has us zeroed and the
barrage will be coming next I said
grabbing Walsh get haul over and take
charge of grey squad tell him I'll be
over there to talk to him later for the
rest of the day I kept the men busy
anything to keep their minds off gray so
let's think about that again you can see
you can see that Richardson is he's
legit and this is your classic situation
where this horrible thing you witnessed
this horrible thing everyone sees it and
what does he say hey look and this is
horrifying you say oh they have us is
zeroed in so we're the next round it's
gonna hit they're gonna hit all around
us so what we need to do is dig in and
we need to do it now and then he just
immediately says halt go take over gray
squad look gray is gone we need to move
on tell him I'll be over to talk to him
later
back to the book what drove me more than
anything was a positive outlook and the
fact that my men were watching
everything I did I often wondered when
we were moving down the road what went
through their minds this is something
that every leader should be thinking
about all the time is that everyone's
watching you you your boys are watching
you and they're judging you as harsh as
that sounds that's what's happening so
you know what give them a good example
I'll tell you what when I see when I
would see leaders in the SEAL Teams that
didn't act that way that didn't act as
if they were being watched all the time
they've they usually slacked off like
what does that look like word oh it
looks like I mean yeah like hey oh no no
I can be a little bit late no one's
watching yeah yeah that's a big one oh
it's okay oh I didn't need this piece of
gear
oh I'll cut the corner on this thing
just all those little tiny things and
not to mention when you're in a
situation like this without watching you
when you say hey you know what they got
a style then we need to get dug in now
all you got that's grace quad now get to
it they're watching that too yeah and
they're seeing and going okay they're
judging and what are they judging their
judging positive the judgment that
Richardson's got his [__] together and
he's going to take care of them mm-hmm
back to the book it had to be a lot
tougher on them than on me while they
had only death dwell on I had dozens of
other things that I must be thinking
about and prepared for what was ahead
where would I be if I were a North
Korean how would I react if we got hit
from the right or left how was our
ammunition water was the bore sighting
of the guns still all right where were
the men were the men taking care of
their feet so he's saying this correctly
so but this is a kind of a different
twist is you know a lot of times you
thought leaders say well I was
responsible for these guys and that was
a heavier weight but for him he's
thinking I was busy with all these other
things all these other guys had to do is
think about the fact that they're about
to die hmm and how that's actually
harder on them do you if you go into
with the perspective that everything is
for you is harder and for for everything
you know for me it's harder cuz I'm the
leader whereas his attitude is fantastic
which is look I'm I have the luxury of
having other things to think about these
poor guys they're just thinking about
you know them being overrun as opposed
to if your attitude was flipped and you
were you know thinking I have it so hard
but these guys have it so easy they
little sense that hmm and that's not
gonna end up net positive for you and
your in your leadership back to the book
the next North Korean assault started
with screams and machine-gun fire but we
beat it back with mortars in our own
machine gunfire running between holes
I made sure everybody was ready for the
next wave Walsh had his section up and
ready to fire halt was all also ready
which was impressive impressive since he
had just taken over from gray the second
attack was worse the North Koreans were
less than 50 yards from us as I fired at
the shadows moving toward us I heard a
frantic voice come over the radio Roy
Rogers 3 the voice said in a deep
southern draw I needs more firepower
I need more firepower I'm about to get
overrun it was lieutenant Jim Brown from
the platoon that was on our left I hope
to hell he got more fire support
we were all hanging by a thread dead
North Korean soldiers were stacking up
in front of our foxholes but they kept
coming wave after wave
I could hear Walsh screaming at the men
to stay in their holes I was frantically
changing the magazine in my carbine as
to the North Koreans were within 10 feet
of me Walsh and Hall saw them too and
opened fire cutting the North Korean
soldiers down
I saw another North Korean to my right
and fired he staggered back and dropped
to the ground
I stayed low in my foxhole and kept
firing straight ahead Hall and Walsh
kept firing to the rear hitting the
North Koreans attempting to move through
our position we had them in a crossfire
and in minutes our position was littered
with North Korean bodies sliding a fresh
magazine into my carbine I poked my head
up waiting for the next wave but it
never came stay alert some of them may
still be alive
if you if you see any movement shoot
them we waited a few minutes and finally
climbed out check around your holes for
live Koreans and he goes on to say that
we dragged the rest of the bodies away
from our position and piled them to one
side I didn't even look at their faces I
didn't care and he talks about the fact
that his medics would try and take care
of the North Korean wounded soldiers
that's pretty impressive
back to the book as daylight peeked over
at its head over the hills at all
scrubby looking infantryman carrying a
carbine approached me from out of the
Mist as he got closer I saw the small
white cross painted on his helmet he
stuck out his hand as he approached
chaplain Kapaun he said giving me a firm
handshake where are you from
chaplain Emil Kapaun from Pilsen Kansas
was a Catholic father who joined the
army toward the end of World War two
he served in Burma in India until May
1946 he returned home and was assigned a
parish in Kansas
but he felt his calling was with the
troops so he rejoined the army in 1948
he joined us in Korea after spending a
few months in Japan his uniform was
dirty and he like the rest of us needed
a shave it was clear he'd spent the
night up close to the fighting and not
safely in the rear there was a
peacefulness about him though that put
me at ease a quiet confidence he seemed
to care where I was from and I watched
him as he spoke to the rest of the
section each time he asked a soldier
where he is from and gave him a firm
handshake it was not long before he had
us all smiling when Kapaun finished
making his rounds he sat down near my
foxhole and took out his pipe it was
missing most of its stem what happened
your pipe I asked as he filled it a
sniper he said shot it out of my mouth a
few days ago we both had a laugh I
noticed the carbine laying across his
lap I thought chaplains couldn't carry
weapons he smiled and nodded if they're
going to shoot at me I'm going to be
ready to shoot back my section was down
to eight men we received two
replacements they showed up with their
gear and clean uniforms one was named
Jackson's one was named Jackson but I
didn't catch the others name Jackson had
a lot of questions about the North
Koreans and where we were on the line
stay close to your foxhole partner and
listen to him I said I didn't see them
again until the next morning we'd been
attacked again but this time we were
able to keep the North Koreans from our
lines but not without cost
three men were gone one missing and two
wounded including both the replacements
we were taking casualties every night
and soon could no longer hold our
position later that night we got orders
to withdraw withdrawing in the daylight
was it bad enough now we are going to
attempt it at night so a couple things
you're gonna hear a lot about this this
chaplain Kapaun and well not a lot as
you should
he's got his own story that needs to be
told and about what he did in his
service and then you know but I tried to
pull out a few sections about him and
then the fact that these guys I mean
they're losing guys all the time you get
two replacements and they're they're
gone by the next morning that's not a
positive outlook on the situation so
they finally get the orders to withdraw
and it's funny not funny but it's
interesting that they're actually not
looking forward to withdrawing at night
mmm you know whereas me my instinct is
like I'd rather go at night right no of
course but you know what if you haven't
trained that way because you can train
even without night vision you can train
to operate at night you learn the
spacing that you need to get you learn
you know certain maneuvers that you do
at nighttime that are easier at
nighttime so night time is not something
to be scared of but these guys I mean
unless you haven't trained that way if
you haven't trained that way man I can't
even imagine what it's like because I
trained so much in the dark and me when
I first got in the SEAL Teams we did
everything in the dark would have night
vision you know we just did we just
patrolled the dark how we do we had
clothes for spacing you learn how to use
persons silhouette in front of you
you're you learn how to adapt your eyes
to the dark those all these things that
you can do to make you a more formidable
night fighter but if you don't train
that way boom you you you're you're in
big trouble
hmm so these guys are starting up their
withdraw back to the book let's go I
whispered I was nervous and one two get
going before another attack
Walsh standing by looked over me Sarge
that's Johnson he's dead so he was too
he was kicking a guy on the ground
saying hey let's go and he's you know
Walsh says Sarge that's Johnson he's
dead I felt terrible it hurt to see
another one of my men dead in the mud I
didn't even know Johnson that well he
was another replacin replacement and I'd
only just learned his name the fact that
I had little time to dwell saved me plus
I knew that if I showed weakness my men
might finally give in and feel sorry for
themselves and I couldn't have that we
needed to stick together I became stoic
and would remain that way for a long
time
again he recognizes that his guys are
looking at him there's two points there
number one he recognizes that his guys
are looking at him and if he breaks down
he's gonna cause breakdowns and number
two the fact that he had little time to
dwell so what does that mean translate
that to your life if something goes
wrong and you decide you're gonna take a
break to reflect on that thing it don't
do that it's better
that's like get back on the horse you
know the old saying like you got to get
back on the horse
that's not only does that help you
overcome the fear but it's better than
sitting around and dwelling on it you
know even if it's something not physical
that you're physically afraid of still
don't sit around and dwell yeah that's a
bad that's a bad thing
yeah like are you saying it gives you
yeah like you something happens right
girl breaks up with you I don't know and
you take the day off from work mmm we're
gonna sit down and look at the pillows
yes gonna jam you up way more but you go
to work and you know your minds occupied
all these tasks and you know you don't
have time to do all and meanwhile I'll
say this your mind is still processing
it right it's not like it's not like
you're at work and so you're not
thinking about it it's in the back and
it's getting worked through your mind
it's doing this job kind of getting a
grip on the situation and then you get
home and like instead of just going home
go train go go directly to the gym
you're actually kind of stoked because
you're not have that pressure of your
girl waiting on you at home to that
country up and get home like no so
you're try and get some extra rounds and
so go get some extra rounds in maybe
stop by that little place on the way
home grab a little bite to eat you know
with one of your buddies yeah and then
go home and when you get home clean your
room yeah you know when you get home
just finished putting together the bit
the bookcase or whatever do something
yeah and now you're tired and now you go
to bed meanwhile like I said in the
background your minds been processing
this and you're starting to realize like
you know what it's not actually that big
of a deal that she left yeah yeah you
know but isn't there that I mean I
wonder why this I'm sure you could kind
of figure it out but you know how
something like bad or traumatic or
whatever will happen and then the person
essentially ignores it or what
evarin focus on work focus on this and
then people close to home or a therapist
or whatever would be like hey I'm scared
I'm concerned because you haven't like
yeah I think there's a dichotomy here
I'm not talking about burying it right
yeah yeah I want to talk about
you still got to contend with it and you
know at some point I'll write down like
the the the protocol the break-up
protocol just straight up right but and
then even like the death protocol like
here's what you're supposed to do now in
these situations I don't have time to do
any protocol right so so this to your
point this can be a problem because if
you're in combat and you lose someone
and then you never have the time to set
aside and contend with it then you get
back and now you get back to America now
you're your family and now you're
getting a new job and you're getting out
of the military in you're making all
this stuff happen you never contended
with what had occurred
so yes you are correct if you don't ever
contend with it and face it then it can
turn into a problem then it turns into
what we talked about with Tim Ferriss
which is they tried you even you tried
to bury it you didn't realize it it was
a seed yeah so you've got it you got to
make sure that it's not a seed that's
gonna grow out of control in the
darkness over there you got it you got
to put the shed some light on it
yeah because because that's how all
right like a lot of the time like oh you
you know you know my girl broke up with
I don't know whatever like something
traumatic and then they'll be like hey I
don't want to think about it I want to
focus on these are the things I don't
want to think about it and they kind of
bury it seems like that could happen oh
and that's what I'm saying there's a
balance that you have to do yeah there's
a balance because you can't just bury it
yeah you have to contend with it but you
want to do it you what you don't want to
do is go overboard and just focus 100%
on I can't believe that this person's
gone whether they died whether they
broke up with you whether they what you
know I get a little you know it's funny
I get little warrior kid questions for
the warrior kid podcasts of my friend is
moving away how can I not be sad and
it's like the same thing like people are
gonna come in and out of your life and
you've got to learn to contend with it
and and what I'm saying is don't focus
on it a hundred percent remember it
contend with it but don't
because we know what that gets you you
just down the dot the darkness the
spiral of darkness what you don't want
to go down no we don't want to avoid it
because then it grows yeah
behind your back yeah yeah well his
situation is kind of different that's
more of a small picture scenario where
where it's like I don't have time to
dwell on my guy who this just happened
him because right now is this important
things going on and again this is where
people get jammed up because they never
contend with it
they never mourn properly they never go
through that process and they look up
you know six months later and they go oh
you know I'm I'm sad I miss my friend
it's like yeah that's okay you know what
you gotta take that's why you you should
be able to take the protocol and just
enact it when there's you know like you
get home from deployment it's like okay
we're going through the protocol because
we look we know yeah or you lose a
friend
car accident whatever whatever situation
you you want it comes time to enact that
protocol boom you you you press play on
the protocol and then you go through the
motions and that gets you get you
through it yeah or at least starts to
get you through it because it's always
gonna be there it's not like you're
gonna be like oh you're always gonna
remember mm-hmm but don't dwell dwell
all right going back to the book it was
another attack and when I say that he's
actually talking about their being told
that they are going to attack again and
this is coming from his boss Maccabee
the entire battalion is going to attack
Hills 573 ridges go direct to the top of
the hill K company will be on the left
we will move in the center and I company
on the right we will attack at daylight
with no artillery or air support boom
yeah I don't like that no the second and
third platoons will attack a breast
second on the right third on the left
Richardson will follow with the 57s in
the center the first Platoon will be in
reserve so there's your plan but there
it is what is a breast
means side-by-side okay yeah and now so
they're they're sort of going through
and and starting to enact this plan and
as they're doing this when his boys says
Sarge we're getting out of here by dark
right I knew the other men wouldn't
speak up but I could just look in their
eyes and see they were scared I just
hope they couldn't see fear in my eyes
we're staying here until we get orders I
said finally answering Walsh in hall I
spoke up loud enough for the whole
section here farther down the hill
marked mortar and artillery fire was
heavy we could see the North Korean
positions and they could see us I was
hoping we were out of grenade range and
too close for their - their position for
them to put mortar fire on us dude what
kind of situation are you in when what
you're hoping for is that you're too far
for grenade range and too close for
mortars yeah man so that just puts you
in the machine gun range basically
unless you've got some kind of dead
space or cover but not a good situation
but you know when that's what you're
hoping for outlook is not good that's
your best option yeah soon instead of
mortars the North Korean soldiers
started sending down taunts we didn't
speak the language but each word had a
charge silence no one talks back I
whispered and put my finger to my lips
not that we knew what they were saying
as the minutes and then hours ticked off
I realized that slowly but surely we
were moving back a foot at a time a guy
would reposition and then the rest of
the whole section would go off of him at
this rate we might be off the hill by
the end of the war I knew one thing
there was no way we were staying
overnight so the situation happens they
start they start actually there's a fire
firing starts and these guys actually
start running down the hill and then
they start receiving small arms fire and
then he rolls into another position and
there's a guy in there named Vail
korte who was another experienced guy in
charge of one of the other sections or
one of the other elements and he comes
in where's the executive officer I asked
vallencourt when I caught up with him he
was killed along with one of the other
platoon leaders the company has
regrouped and tried to come back up the
hill but it was ripped apart by heavy
mortar and artillery fire we lost two
lieutenants and two platoons took heavy
losses so that's that continues and
again you got to get this book so you
can get these details and not reading
them all if there's the detailed combat
for anyone that's in combat arms of any
kind get order this book immediately
because there's so much good information
in it
that I'm not covering so these guys
they're retreating from that attack they
get to like an orchard situation and
there's a colonel that's in charge of
the regiment and this guy Maccabee who's
the company commander he comes up and
here we go maccabe's kind of talking
with and brings Richardson over sergeant
Richard
sergeant Richardson and his men were the
last ones off the hill MacCabe told
Colonel Johnson how your men doing the
colonel asked looking over my shoulder
at the men finishing up their letter to
Sears that this little joke that they
had made earlier okay but very tired
Johnson nodded and shook my hand try and
get some rest tonight
he started to walk away frustrated with
the attack I knew this was my chance to
speak my mind and the mind of my men I
want to know how many more times we were
going to have to climb up a hill only
did leave it and fight our way up
another from my point of view we were
just getting our asses kicked how are we
doing it seems like we never make any
headway Johnson stopped
sergeant Richardson you tell your men
they did a great job against great odds
we have stopped the North Koreans main
attack I turned away and slowly walked
back toward the men I thought to myself
how great
Hall and higly war it was their courage
and bravery that held us together as I
looked at them it almost brought tears
to my eyes
Johnson's news had an immediate impact
on my section
we no longer dragged ass instead we
seemed hopeful even optimistic so again
this is a good point that when you're in
a leadership position your little words
have significant impact and you might
not realize it and I experienced that a
lot with leaders not only in combat or
in the military but I see that with
leaders in the civilian sector where
they don't realize the weight that they
carry and this will even be like the CEO
of a company will will say something
maybe it's off the cuff and it's a
negative thing and it has a negative
impact but they also don't realize how
positive it can be when they say
something positive so if you're in a
leadership position everyone smile every
once in a while throw out some love keep
people right I'm not saying you know
Lafe likes to use the word false
cheerleading which is definitely yeah
that's a that's a good term you know
which is hey you've done a great job
when you didn't do a great job and
cheerleaders cheerleaders cheer pretty
much no matter what just to sound yeah
this is what their job is they cheered
you hey good job even though you're down
47 to 0 like they don't stop right I
don't think things up they just keep
keep cheering keeps hearing so I guess
you don't even have to say false
cheerleader you just say straight chilly
eight well yeah oh I guess when they're
when is winning this yes then it's
positive right yeah so hey let me ask
you this about false cheerleading so
because that came up in the mustard by
the way someone thought that it was just
like focusing on the positives and not
the negatives and they were like that's
false cheerleading where they implied
that that's what and if it was like no
false cheerleading is when you're
cheering for someone even though they're
not doing a pigeon yeah we're making
statements that are factually untrue
right hey echo you did a great job
putting out a bunch of videos this last
year yeah well that's actually factually
untrue and I wouldn't be able to say
that to you yes I put out a limited
number of videos yeah but if you were to
say hey those are real quality and not
quantity
like that would be fact that would be
factually true - yeah yeah actually
technically that's an opinion but hey
okay so what about this here's my
question
so if well let's say okay I'm doing like
this um you know 60% of my workload is
great and then there's 40 that's like
hey you got to change this and then I
sort of just sort of downplay the 40 you
tonight not meet you like my beau
downplay the 40 just to encourage me
whatever reason um and you really uh
play that the 60 is that false
cheerleading it is but there's a little
bit more strategy behind this because as
your leader I wouldn't only talk to you
one time yeah right I'm talking to you
over a period of time so what my first
comment to you might be something like
hey echo that 60 percent that you're
over there you're crossed it out that's
you're doing a great job super so you
know some of the other stuff not quite
there yet but but actually the first
time I talked to you might be like hey
you're you're crushing it you're doing
awesome
yeah I might of you to mention that
forty percent because I'm thinking hey
if this guy gets encouraged he's gonna
be like yeah I'm gonna do a little bit
more right and yeah that you just might
pick up the slack
anyways on your own accord because
you're just encouraged by the whole the
whole positivity that I'm giving you
yeah so that's cool right well maybe it
doesn't work so now I might have to come
just a little bit more direct right hey
I notice that you know this 60% over
here that you're dominating and it's
awesome well is there something with
this 40% over here that's different that
you know that it comes because it seems
to be like a different level and it's
not up to 60% is there something that's
different maybe I find learning
something right but I give you the
opportunity well yeah it's because of
this that whatever maybe we can correct
it and then if that doesn't work then
maybe I have to amplify or escalate a
little bit more right and then it's hey
man the 60% you're doing Wow awesome
yeah there's there's also that 40% that
when I'm looking at it I'm I'm actually
wondering if it's the same guy for you
to be able to do this over here and
still kind of throw this in the mix to
kind of
yeah it doesn't make sense to me anymore
I'm again my whole thing would be trying
to figure out why you're slacking in
that area yeah if you're doing 60% great
why are you doing 40 put that let's hope
there's a reason behind that yeah and so
once we find out what that reason is
it's like okay and so I'm gonna slowly
escalate and and start until I get to
the point you know if we go to six
months and I've done and I've pulled out
whatever obstacles in yourway because
there was some obstacles on the 40
percent was like well we weren't getting
that information at time okay well so
now I start getting you an information
at time and he said well I didn't have
the resources okay well then I throw you
another person to help you and you're
still slacking so eventually you know
I'm gonna have to come a little bit more
direct and be less than man the 60%
I appreciate the 40% is actually
starting to hurt us mm-hmm and either
you need to step it up which is what I'm
hoping because I see nothing but
potential in you or I might actually
have to bring someone else in that can
kind of handle a hundred percent you see
where I'm coming from yes and it would
even escalate from there so so yeah
there's I don't think of things as black
and white conversations like hey I just
need to go in and drop the hammer today
cuz I don't I don't I'd rather I'd
rather have you recognize it right I'd
rather have you realize that that
there's a problem with that forty
percent now I might say something in
just omit the forty percent like when I
first talked to you man there's 60
percent of this stuff already that
you're doing is awesome yeah and I'm
giving you the benefit of the doubt that
you're gonna straight know about other
40 percent yeah get out your ruler and
get it straight sure of course the ruler
but oh okay so technically yeah so your
whole campaign yeah is not false
cheerleading that no so it's like but
but let's say you just stuck let's say
that for that first one that's step one
right a spot on all five steps so if you
just stuck with step one I guess it
depends on the reason too right so I'm
like hey great this 60% is awesome and
don't even mention the 40% because I
don't want any conflict with that guy or
I'm scared too you know confront them or
I'm scared for that that conversation is
what you should be realistically scared
of is if you're doing if you're busting
your ass to do that 60% great and all I
come in do say like hey the 60% is good
but the other 40% sucks I discourage you
you know you're like I can't do anything
right for jock
so now you're not your 60% right there's
a good answer you don't even get the 60%
now you go down the 50% and then 40% is
good and 60% back yeah I don't want that
I want you to be on board with the
program I want you to be like oh man I
can work a little bit more and work a
little bit harder discipline myself a
little bit better and I could actually
get 70% and then let's see what Jocko
comes in here and says when he's all
fired up that I did 60 but watch this
yeah so this is a whole thing so thank
you almost same almost that falls
cheerleading I guess okay I was gonna
say you could almost say if all sterling
cheerleading actually has its little
spot is it in a bigger can be used in a
campaign but I guess technically if it
is it's a bit by its very nature if it's
part of a big campaign it's not false
cheerleading it's just a maybe strategic
move over like just think of a little
kid I mean let's just break it down to
the fundamental realities of life a
little kid if you take a little kid that
does something okay let's say the kid
tries to draw a rabbit and was it look
like it was really worth it right so if
you say okay I'm not gonna reuse Falls
cheerleading hey kid
yeah that look doesn't look like a
rabbit it looks like a stick you'll fail
is that kid gonna draw another rabbit if
you say oh I really like that you try I
can see where the eyes should go yeah
you know and they get a little bit can I
hang this up I'm gonna hang this up on
my refrigerator what does that kid wanna
do now draw more does that translate
directly to adults oh yes it most oh yes
it does doesn't always translate
horizontal of course not it doesn't
trans I don't represent but because
there's some people that are of course
there's some people are just trying to
skate and do the minimum and if you say
like hey good job you're like okay cool
thanks no I'm just gonna keep doing
whatever you told me but if you're you
know forget again for an extra teacher
core in a campaign we're trying to make
things happen it's like yeah you know
what
hmm hey echo man that stuff
figure the first time you ever made a
video yeah imagine if I said you know I
mean decent work you know not exactly i
grabbing though would you been excited
to make more videos probably yeah
probably not yeah I mean you'd probably
like okay well whatever I guess maybe
this isn't for me
or maybe I won't make videos for this
guy yeah for this guy that's you know
but if I was like oh man I really like
to wait that was some good affair that
wasn't you know what I mean yeah then
you go oh yeah I'm like he's in the game
with me well son we're team we're not
against each other yeah so I'm just
trying to unify things and bring things
together yeah I might even come back to
you to improve myself more with yes a
way ahead that yeah we're a team now
yeah that's a good way to do my best
leaders that I had all I wanted to do is
do better for them they and they never
they might give me critique but it was
like the kind of critique that makes you
feel guilty about being alive wait a
minute I can't really they like this you
know I wish you know if we could do this
a little bit more man that would be
really nice and like calm and then you
have to also remember that people have
different levels of sensitivities right
yeah because for you like especially
when it's something that they were
deeply care about yeah when you critique
them there's almost no one that takes
that critique well right oh you want to
tell me about oh you want tell me about
whatever I did this drawing like a
little kid right the kid tries to do
good drawing you know you tell him that
the drawings no good that breaks their
heart yeah evil yeah so you're right is
that false cheerleading no that's part
of a campaign plan is it good if the kid
draws a stick and you're like that's the
most amazing drawing I've ever seen well
now what's this is to Leif's point if
you kid draws a stick and supposed to be
a rabbit and you go that's the most
amazing rabbit I've ever seen drawn now
let me ask you this is that kid gonna
try and improve at all no and he'll
probably not take criticism because they
start getting used to like never having
everything I do is great and I think
that one applies more to adults
when you say that doing adult like man
that's the best thing I've ever seen
they're like oh yeah you know they're a
little bit more egotist yeah a little
bit more yeah little kids are like well
it kind of surprised if you tell them
that you're Plus they wouldn't really
believe you okay look I'm only six but
that's a stick as far as I'm concerned I
tried to make a rabbit I got I got an
ear on there anyways you know after that
don't know yeah
yeah I could see that - yes so there you
go
meanwhile back in Korea here's what's
going on they're under another attack it
is you can see there's a little pattern
developing it's just we're getting
attacked we're getting attacked we're
getting attacked we're getting attacked
that's what's going on we could see the
North Koreans pouring over the hill the
North Korean artillery fire followed K
company down the hill the ground shook
like an earthquake as the rounds walked
towards us I hugged the bottom of the
side of the hole all I could think about
was around landing straight on top of me
if that happened I'd never know I pulled
my helmet and gritted my teeth I was
starting to lose it now again this is
just continued their continuing getting
hammered and Walsh comes over are we
going to stay goddammit just stay in
these holes until I tell you differently
I raced back to my hole on the way a
young lieutenant ran by me he was scared
he was so scared his voice cracked when
he screamed at me get out of here fall
back
who the hell are you I barked there were
men still trying to get back and if we
left they wouldn't have a chance in hell
so he his group is trying to provide
cover fire for the groups that are now
retreating he didn't stop and I never
got his name he just yelled to fall back
you're full of [__] I yelled at him we
can't leave here we have to help these
men yeah this is the he's keeping order
in this retreat several other members of
K company passed me following the
lieutenant I saw some of my men getting
out of their holes you sons of [__]
get back in your goddamn holes I cook I
yelled get back they scrambled back
rounds started to crash around us again
I could hear the K company men scream as
shrapnel shower
them slicing into their skin larger
pieces punched holes in their chests or
sheared off their limbs their screams
filled in the silence between the
crashes of artillery shells I was not
going to be able to control this [__]
situation much longer Walsh just stared
at me with a vacant look don't lose it
now I thought another barrage landed
nearby I put my head down my ears
started ringing smoke was down on the
bottom of the hole again the artillery
fire finally stopped the screaming for
the medics began go check your men I
told wall shaking him out of his stupor
I headed over to Hall's position he had
the same vacant look as Walsh men from
Cake Company were moving down the ridge
carrying the wounded everybody was
bleeding or bandaged I kept my men
focused on the hill waiting for the
North Koreans to counter-attack but they
never came neither did the artillery it
wasn't long and I was told to withdraw
off the hill he talks about the Korean
augmentation to the US Army or at KATUSA
program k80 USA so Korean augmentation
to the US Army and this was like
soldiers he describes it here
KATUSA soldiers were young men picked up
in larger cities given a couple weeks
training in son assigned to the American
units despite the language barriers the
koreans fell right in line with the rest
of us when we marched they kept up when
we fought they stood their ground - over
the next few days we continued to attack
to the west it was a knock-down drag-out
slugfest the North Koreans attacked us
with abandon and tried to overwhelm us
with numbers they were fanatical one
regimental commander said after the war
that the North Koreans had no
consideration for the loss of life they
have no hesitancy in losing 500 lives to
gain a small piece of ground
it took us three more days to take two
more North Korean positions we uncovered
large ammunition caches and killed 72
and captured 200
all at a great price I lost two more men
and the company suffered a total of four
killed with 13 wounded the loss has
reduced our strength to around 53 men
but the enemy was now on the run and we
held the river river lined the morale
went sky-high so they kind of turned the
tables a little bit as they went on the
attack and the counter-offensive and
then they're continuing to push and as
they're as they're heading down the road
all of a sudden North Korean machine
guns started spraying the road they had
us in the open the North Koreans had us
pinned down and unable to push into the
village which is what their what their
objective was i heard the rumbling first
peeking over the dike i saw 3
russian-made t-34 tanks I could tell
they were t-34s because of the narrow
turret that sat on top of the almost
pyramid-shaped body the tanks had led
the charge against Nazi Germany in World
War 2 the t-34 dominated the German
tanks because the Russian tanks could
race over the deep mud and snow of the
Eastern Front after the war the Soviet
sold them to their communist allies the
North Korean invasion was spearheaded by
t-34 tanks the North Korean lead tech
was almost on us it stopped and the main
guns started to slowly turn in our
direction I looked at the road and saw a
bazooka gunner jump out of the rice
paddy run to the middle of the road
stomp shoulder the tube aiming at the
tank I thought this guy must have nerves
of steel it was a modern-day David and
Goliath Wham the rocket smashed into the
tank and bounced off the goddamn thing
was a dud or the gunner was too close
and the Rockets did not have time to arm
a burst from the tank's machine gun
opened up and quickly cut the American
gunner down I scrambled down the muddy
Dyke screaming at he glee to get to his
gun up machine gun rounds from the tanks
gunner sprayed me with mud go for the
treads I screamed I
Mashti Lee's assistant gunner slide
around under the 57 on his shoulder and
tapped him on the helmet I slid to a
stop and buried my head in my hands I
felt the concussion before I heard the
round race by and hit the tank the arm
of Hulk tried to shake off the blast but
when it moved I watched the tread roll
off the wheels the turret still worked
and I could see it moved back and forth
searching for targets staying out of the
North Korean sights I motioned to Walsh
to get his gun on the second tank in
minutes I heard another blast from the
57 soon the two tanks unable to get
there by their crippled mate reversed
and headed back to the village just
taking out tanks with bazookas
unbelievable the next morning we started
out toward the hill in the village a
thick early morning fog hung low over
the rice paddies visibility was zero we
were stiff wet and very anxious as we
started moving toward the objective up
ahead
I saw soldiers walk through the North
Korean positions and continue toward the
village climbing like the last dike we
ran up on a road covered in North Korean
bodies they were in a heap torn apart by
shrapnel mules and Boake and broken
equipment sat motionless nearby body
parts were strewn on both sides of the
road I saw men lying dead and still
chained to the machine guns they were
pulling as the fog lifted the sight
became even more gruesome our artillery
had caught them trying to withdraw the
same scene played over and over again as
we moved up the road into the village we
didn't face a fight taking this position
every mile we moved north my outlook
changed the whole section looked and
acted more self-confident when we got
into a fight we enjoyed it the killing
was quickly becoming revenge rather than
the sucess 'ti rather than necessity to
gain ground and drive the North Koreans
out we were still being killed only now
we were the aggressors and they were
dying in their holes
knew we were better fighters and had
held them under tremendous odds now the
tables were turned and they did not have
the will or resolve to accomplish what
we had in Pusan during the darkest days
of summer so the Momentum's kind of
changed and these guys are feeling
feeling good about the whole situation
as they and there's something good
there's something that feels good about
being on offense right being on offenses
is where we want to be we don't want to
be on defense and this confidence
continues as they continue to advance
early the next morning we were back on
foot advancing toward the North Koreans
behind the three American tanks we were
receiving heavy heavy artillery fire and
tried to stay close to the tanks hoping
the armor would shield us from the
shrapnel flying through the air one
second I was looking back to make sure
Walsh's squad was keeping up and the
next I was stunned a shell landed on the
tank sending shrapnel and fired into the
air the explosion was deafening and I
stumbled back dazed falling down in the
tracks behind the tank
I saw the crew crawling out of the
escape hatch machine gun fire was
kicking up dirt all around me as I
hugged the ground I could see two
tankers lying under the tank they were
wounded and couldn't crawl away from the
Hulk Walsh I screamed help me get these
guys a couple of artillery rounds net
landed on the road I felt a sharp hop
pain in my left shoulder you all right
Walsh asked as he raced to my side yeah
I said shaking my head trying to
reassure him I didn't have time to worry
about it the machine-gun rounds pinged
off the armor as I crawled underneath
the tank and grabbed one of the tankers
by his collar pain shot through my arm
and my shoulder felt hot and weak I let
go but hung on with my good hand
Walsh grabbed the other tanker and we
dragged the pair into a nearby ditch
medic medic I screamed so this again
there's a slight heroism after heroism
after heroism in this book and I brought
bring up some of them but I don't bring
up all of them because we just don't
have I'm not gonna read the whole book
you got a bye
book continuing I squatted down and
tried to take off my gear and jacket so
the medic could get to the wound because
I obviously got hit in the shoulder my
left hand shook as I peeled off the
shirt now a few shades darker from the
blood the medic arrived with Walsh he
wiped away the blood with a wad of gauze
and started to bandage the gash he was
on the back side of my shoulder and I
couldn't see the wound a few pieces of
shrapnel the medic said you can move it
right probably nothing torn or broken so
now he's you know he's wounded it's not
too severe not exactly a good deal
though you know you think about you you
think about you're in an athletic
competition which is what this is and on
top of that there's a massive amount of
mental stress and on top of that you got
to make decisions and on top of that you
get you get a big gash in your shoulder
hmm a couple days later we were we sat
overlooking the 38th parallel we'd push
the North Koreans back now and awaited
orders to attack sitting in my foxhole I
watched as the full moon began to rise I
got the feeling that there was something
safe and secure as it washed and gently
over us I felt like God was protecting
us or surely trying to help at least
he'd kept me alive even though my
shoulder throbbed if only we were back
home we could all go to sleep under the
moon's calming light and wake up safe to
the warmth of the Sun
now that shoulder wound that he kind of
blew off actually isn't is not all that
good he starts getting a little uh
starts getting a little infection and it
passes out from it I woke up this time
they carried me back to the battalions
aid station the medics set the stretcher
on a dirt floor doctor comes in you're
lucky had you waited and no longer the
infection would have spread some time
goes by the next day I felt fine
the doctors had me on a jello diet so
when the doctor came on came on his
rounds I told him I wanted to leave I
need to go back to my unit I said
typical fashion the of the American
Doughboy the American grunt they get
wounded what do they want to do they
want to go back they want to go back
with their team and that's exactly what
he what he does and a couple days later
he gets back with his unit and of course
what are they doing they're going on
attack and as they're going on attack
back to the book all of a sudden there
was a thunderous roar as an artillery
barrage hit us I was blown straight up
in the air
my feet were over my head I came down on
my shoulder in my head the mud soften
the blow
grabbing my helmet I yelled for my
section to run forward out of the
Killzone three guys in front of me and
two behind me were wounded
I could hear the moaning as they clutch
their stomachs and legs I checked myself
I had escaped without a scratch
medics hurried to the down men I I
looked back and saw Healy standing days
to get moving I yelled he looked at me
with a funny expression on his face and
looked down at his waist he had been hit
by shrapnel in the stomach I could see
the blood soaking through his fatigues
I'm hit wretch get down I said and I
hollered medic he fell to his knees and
rolled over onto his back I was torn I
wanted to run to him but I had to keep
the rest of the section moving it was
one of those choices that you never want
to make I saw the medics coming and
turned to join the other men good luck
buddy see you later I screamed over my
shoulder I couldn't look back but I knew
I probably never see Healy again a
stomach wound I thought Jesus Christ I
hope he makes it I wanted to sit down
and cry but this was not the time or
place for that I had damn near lost a
whole squad
there was only one way to go at the hill
so now they're trying to take the hill
there's only one way to go at the hill
and it was straightforward I looked
across the open space we were going to
cross there was little cover this was
going to be tough there was no time to
dwell on he glee or our dwindling
numbers the longer we sat behind the
railroad embankment the tougher it would
be to get started
Brahms er was waiting to get artillery
support the same guys I had dinner with
I hope they remembered what I told them
and come through leaning back against
the embankment I saw Alan and the Korean
hustling across the field each carrying
two pack boards with ammo get ready
Brahms er said I gripped my rifle and
closed my eyes my mind knew going
forward was crazy but I willed my legs
to move soon I was running and leading
the rest of the section across the
paddies mortar and artillery fire
crashed around me but I didn't notice I
only saw the flashes of the North Korean
machineguns ahead of me I stayed close
to Mac I could hear him hollering too at
his squad to move to my right I saw that
Walsh was right beside us he had his
squad moving it all seemed almost normal
it was just another day another attack
so you're getting mortar and artillery
fire crashing all around you but you're
not paying attention that because you're
really paying attention to the damn
muzzle flashes from the Korean machine
guns that are right in front of you when
they may end up pulling off that attack
and again get the book so you can get
some of those details when he attacks
complete he writes I was not a religious
person but I felt like one that day I
gave thanks with Walsh for our gift of
life after services that evening we
turned in our basic load of ammunition
another sure sign that it was over so
just to rehash that last little
statement there turning in their
ammunition because they're getting a
positive feeling like they've been doing
this good fighting they've been on the
pursuit and they were kind of on the
defensive in the beginning
they go back on the counter-attack and
now they're feeling pretty good and now
they they get hey you know what you can
turn in your ammunition think about that
but back to the book that night we got
orders to move but not home
we were headed north to the town of
Busan I was a corporal when we arrived
in Korea now less than 67 days later I
was going to be a master sergeant the
Army's highest noncommissioned officers
rank the promotion's couldn't have come
at a better time with the war winding
down I was sure this would be the last
of the fast promotions so he's actually
again these guys think that they're
doing a good job and they kind of think
that things are heading in their
direction and yeah 1950 I mean we know
just from history that this war is not
even close to over yet and yeah but
that's the weather feeling and can you
imagine I mean he's he's at the highest
ease of ease at peace of Master Sergeant
right now 67 days he got promoted
through all the ranks that's how many
guys that's how many guys were wounded
her killed
that they needed him to be promoted to
run these units so they now get sent
into a position where they're holding a
bridge and while they're holding this
bridge he sends a couple guys out on
recon to take a look around and they
come back and he says what the hell is
that I asked him it's just an old glove
and a shovel it's all wet it's probably
been there for weeks he said in a
defiant tone and that's one of the guys
that were on the recon talking that was
on the recon talking it didn't look like
any glove I had seen before it was large
and padded what else did you find I shot
back just some old positions nothing to
worry about I was a little concerned now
and continued to quiz him on how many
holes there were up there around five or
six the sergeant said was the dirt wet
or dry
goddamn and I don't know it was pitch
black I'm telling you there's nothing up
on that [__] hill the smog sergeant
snapped at me
you can guess what's coming you find a
shovel up there guess what's going on
there digging in that's what's going on
there digging in and these gloves these
kind of heavy gloves you know probably
resupply from the Chinese that's why I
didn't recognize them
so they hadn't really encountered the
Chinese yet that we're about to attack
in massive numbers back to the book
around 4:00 a.m. the hill erupted four
machine guns from the high hills on the
south end of the bridge opened up two
guns cross firing on each end of the
bridge the tracers from the machine gun
were skipping off the concrete like
firecrackers my guys quickly man the 57
recoilless rifle and got off a few
rounds it did little immediately we
started getting hit with mortar fire my
radio was shot up and I tried to get the
company on the landline but it was out
to my mind was on my men I'd lost to in
the opening barrage and I had lost track
of the two men on the south side of the
bridge this attack didn't make sense too
much firepower for a few stragglers
so he's again looking back to the recon
report that he got it looked like the
4th of July fireworks as tracers skipped
off the concrete but I soon realized
that some of the fire was coming from
our left flank Jesus Christ it was our
own company firing at us so we got a
little blue on blue going down which
again for folks that are in the military
blue on blue is a real thing and if you
don't pay attention and you don't plan
for it can absolutely happen to you know
life was saying that the other day if
you would have asked him before we went
on deployment one of the chances that
you're involved in a blue on blue
situation the Folio non-deployment
layman like no chance that would never
happen to us and during deployment you
know there was there was the I think we
talked about three blue on blue
possibilities well one real and then two
possibilities in the in extreme
ownership and we know one is the opening
story of blue on blue one is Lafe with
Chris Kyle who's getting ready to take a
shot and you know life is basically
getting asked hey take that guy out and
leave puts the brakes on it
it turns out being friendly US Army
soldiers and then one where I got guys
on the rooftop of a building and there's
a Bradley Fighting Vehicle that's
wanting to engage it with 25 millimeter
chain gun and they're looking they're
reporting that they're looking at one
building but they're actually looking
and I'm and all indications are yes you
can engage those are enemy snipers on
that rooftop take him out but on the
same block a few buildings down it was
actually considered was actually like
probably a couple blocks away was my
guys and that gunner in that Bradley
that was reporting it he just got a
little bit a little bit off on which
building was which building oh yeah so
he was actually pointing at one building
and just thought he was yes so he's
looking through they have really good
imagery on those buildings especially
the thermo so you can see like white-hot
and he's looking at a building down this
long street and he's reporting I don't
write for you what the buildings were
but the building he's you know reporting
building 50 I got enemy any personnel on
the rooftop and my guys were in building
100 yeah so he's asking does anyone have
any true you know any friendly troops in
building 50 no no one has any troops in
building 50 oh there's there's enemy
with with scoped weapons there and
everyone's thinking hey this is the
sniper that's been killing our guys by
the way right let's take him out and
then looking at via and what I actually
told him to do I was like hey before and
and the reason I was heads up was
because we had blue on blue I knew that
this was a possibility
so I said count the buildings from your
intersection up to the target building
mhm and so that it just went quiet for a
little while and he comes back as a
standby because he caught himself you
know keys you can see on the battle map
it's like okay one two three four five
six seven and that's what whatever he
gets to 12 he's like oh wait I'm in the
wrong spot and you realized it says I
got you know so stood him down but yeah
you don't want to be on a rooftop
getting hit with 50 or 25 millimeter
chain gun from a Bradley Fighting
Vehicle it's not gonna be a good
situation no
at all and so the same things going on
here you got firefight going on at night
you got troops moving around and these
guys are getting lit up by their own men
all kinds of ways tactically to
deconflict these things but you have to
pay attention to and one of the things
you have to do is you have to have the
humility to recognize that it can
actually happen yeah back to the book
the Koreans were all over the place Mac
was hit worse than he's thought I could
feel his back it was drenched in blood
he started to choke I talked to him but
he didn't answer I laid him down and at
the same time hollered to the rest of
the men to pull in tighter around the
road I had four men left our two jeeps
were shot up one was on fire I knew at
this point we could not hold the bridge
get the breach get the breach block from
the 57 and throw it in the river I
yelled to my guys so so that's sort of
like that's like one of those when you
make that call right there which is
disable our weapon permanently because
we're gonna not make it we don't want
the enemy to be able to use this when
they capture it in a matter of minutes
that's what he's saying
his you know get the breach block out
and throw it in the river and then of
course the North Koreans attacked again
and got within 20 feet before we stopped
them I rushed to the other side of the
road and got slammed to the ground from
an explosion confused I stumbled into a
nearby ditch my head was ringing I
checked Mac he was dead and so were the
other two men on his side of the road
with only two men left we had to leave
the bridge I shoved a grenade in the
breech of the 57 the grenade exploded
destroying the gun and we started
pushing up the ditch away from the
bridge I couldn't see or hear anything
we had not gone very far when the
pointman told me someone was coming down
the ditch toward us I took a knee and
reread eat my rifle hold your fire until
they get closer I whispered the point
man yelled quickly back Sarge their own
guys to two of them from battalion come
over here what's going on I barked at
them the men looked crazed both were
talking a mile a minute and I tried to
settle them down look take it easy I
told them slowly tell me what you know
the battalion got hit they were in the
headquarters before we knew it the whole
damn place was a mess one of the
soldiers said they were dead and wounded
all over everything was shot up it
looked like an artillery barrage made a
direct hit it was total chaos what are
you two trying to do I asked they said
they were trying to make contact with
someone Sarge I'm Taylor one of Walsh's
men the other guy is from 1st battalion
in the dark I didn't recognize him
where's Walsh
they're all dead Sarge Taylor said
so they make movement towards that
battalion headquarters area and there's
still some friendlies there we stumbled
into the battalion headquarters area and
I introduced myself and asked Jones what
the situation was it was not good there
were 30 or 40 wounded her dead doc
Anderson and the chaplain and are in the
command post trying to take care of the
wounded
Jones thought the battalion commander
was dead they just walked in on them and
shot up the whole damn place so at this
point they kind of Ziggy out of there
into a tree line and we got into the
wood line and threw ourselves to the
ground completely exhausted
and from there the chaplain moved on to
another position but before he left he
told me we were fighting the Chinese
we'd heard rumors about the Chinese
soldiers coming over the border that
pretty much confirmed what I had fought
for the last couple of hours Jones had
basically told me when he mentioned that
there quilted uniform jackets looked
much different than the North Koreans
first lieutenant Phil Peterson and Walt
Mayo had also scrambled into our
perimeter both officers were artillery
forward observers but had lost their
radios in the confusion they've gotten
reports hours before the attack that the
Chinese were in the area
the Chinese soldiered soldiers had
crossed the yellow to protect electrical
generators along the river that night
Peterson had seen a Chinese prisoner in
his quilted jacket but had no idea the
danger we were in they'd been ordered
back to the battalion and then tried to
escape when artillery unit tried to save
their own howitzers but the Chinese had
already cut the road we were trapped for
the rest of the day we set up our
defenses we knew the Chinese would come
for us that night so that's it right now
they're there surrounded and they set up
a perimeter to the best of their ability
and they got a bunch of wounded they're
low on ammunition they're low on food
too low on water and so a perimeter is
basically for those that don't know you
set up 360-degree security perimeter you
dig some foxholes you put machine guns
pointing out it's your it's your last
stand the situation now it doesn't
always the last stand because when
you're on a normal Patrol you set up a
perimeter anytime you stop you set up
360-degree security and in this
situation that's what they're doing
they're set up their perimeter to the
best of their ability with what they've
got left and then there's a little
command post in the center of the
perimeter and here we go back to the
book inside the command post I knew what
the officers were talking about it was a
forbidden subject what worried what were
we going to do with the wounded in the
terrible final moat moment that everyone
knew was coming
the battalion surgeon doc Anderson and
the chaplain were doing what they could
for about 40 wounded men but we couldn't
hold out for long without a relief
column meaning people coming to back
them up and if we had to run the wounded
officers were going to have to decide
whether or not to leave themselves and
the other wounded men behind to the
mercies of the enemy and once he kind of
hears that inside the center of the
perimeter during the at the command post
there he goes back out to his edge of
the perimeter and then here we go back
to look I saw a group of 20 men running
right at us they were Americans and were
hollering and waving at us
I prayed they were they were the lead
element of a relief column because of
course they're hearing rumors that
someone's gonna come there's big there's
friendlies on the way that's what
they're getting they're kind of and it I
wasn't clear where they were getting
those rumors from or whether they were
just assuming like hey we're here
Americans are gonna come to get us
they've got to be sending a relief
battalion we just need to hang on
so that's what he's saying I prayed that
they were the lead element of a relief
column the other guys were cheering them
on as they made the short dash to our
trench they slid inside their Jeff's
chest heaving what unit are you guys
from I asked second of the eighth an
officer said between deep breaths the
stragglers pushed by us and collapsed in
the center of the perimeter everyone's
morale sank lower than whale [__]
the energy and excitement seemed to
deflate from the men in the trench and
all at once their heads hung and
shoulders dipped these guys weren't a
relief column they were just more
stragglers from the second battalion I
couldn't shake the thought that no one
was coming for us
[Music]
there's a soldier that he talks about a
Polish guy I mean American guy but of
Polish descent last names of Wallach
it's later that day why so now they're
in their perimeter
later that day Wallach sent for me I
walked across the west side of the
perimeter and saw him standing near a
machine gun positioned
he looked concerned and started pointing
out towards what looked like an open
field look over there he said I watched
where he was pointing I didn't see
anything I looked at him and shrugged my
soldiers no keep looking he said this
time staring intently then I saw it a
faint shovel full of dirt flying right
into the air the little bastards were
digging a trench there were about a half
dozen or so digging a path right for us
our machine guns had been keeping them
at a distance but when their trench was
done they could move under cover right
up to the edge of our trenches so that's
a determined enemy they're just gonna
spend all day digging toward you mm-hmm
as clandestine as they can but they can
only keep it so clandestine and no one
the only only one soldier noticed
back to the book sunset was a bad time
night always meant another attack it
started with a probe a few Chinese
soldiers would move up to the perimeter
followed by a short and violent
firefight shortly after the probe the
artillery and mortar fire would start
followed by the demonic ball of brass
bugles and whistles as the Chinese
infantry attacked and now he's talking
about his guys the men looked at me with
weary and tired eyes all of us had
scruffy beards and our skin was caked
with mud and blood none of the soldiers
could look at me
they knew that they wouldn't survive
unless they got up and fought but they
just sat there they were not cowards
just frozen by fear for some this was
their first taste of combat boys who
overnight were forced to become men I
could only imagine the terror they must
have been through must have been going
through you've got two choices
I yelled get up and get to the line or
I'll shoot you that shocked them into
action I don't think they thought I
would shoot them I'd no sooner finished
prodding the men out of their interior
holes than one hell of a fight took
place at the battalion command post I
knew there were mostly wounded soldiers
there and I feared for Jones the lone
man on the machine-gun but I had my own
problems the bugles and whistles broke
the silence and the Chinese rushed the
east side of our perimeter they came in
waves straight into our fire as quickly
as they fell more appeared they moved
into our fire like they were possessed I
raced from trench to trench moving men
where the Chinese concentrated their
attack when their attack on the east
side slowed they launched an attack on
the west side although we were dug in
our casualties were mounting I kept
moving men to wear the most Chinese were
concentrated the attack slowed down but
it was not long before they began an
assault on the west side of the
perimeter now they get this idea as
these attacks are taking place there's
these trucks that were their kind of
abandoned trucks and they figure it's
nighttime if they can set these trucks
on fire then it'll allow them to see the
enemy
and so that's what they do they want
once one of these attacks starts they
say shot the gas tanks and then shot
tracers until all the vehicles were on
fire when the Chinese infantrymen ran
past we could see them silhouetted
against the light it was a shooting
gallery we cut down the first wave only
to watch the next ones climb over their
comrades and keep coming we mowed down
the next wave but they still kept coming
for the rest of the night the Chinese
came at us like waves to the shore but
each time we stopped them they never
reached the perimeter the next morning
we took stock of our situation water and
food were a problem but ammunition and
the wounded were our biggest concern we
had 85 able-bodied men left out of about
200 the rest were dead or wounded
we were also out of morphine and the
screams of the wounded were starting to
have an impact on the rest of the men I
could see in their eyes
a tired Haggard look a relief calm is
calling for us they'll get through today
I told the men as I walked the line I
said it over and over again hoping to
calm them and as I realized in hindsight
probably hoping to convince myself I
hope to hell I was right now this is
just a little report again about
chaplain Kapaun and he gets a report
richardson gets a report and it says
this the doc said that when the Chinese
got into the dugout chaplain Kapaun
stopped them from killing all the
wounded by surrendering himself the
Chinese took him and 15 of the walking
wounded including my old company
commander captain Maccabee what coupon
did was heroic stopping the Chinese when
he left he was carrying sergeant Miller
so chaplain Kapaun just
but once again heroic actions saving the
lives of these guys before they were
slaughtered by the Chinese by
surrendering himself when I got back I
organized about a dozen guys to follow
me out of the perimeter and gather up
some of the Chinese weapons and
ammunition we were out of almost
everything but lying in front of us were
weapons and ammunition including
much-needed grenades before we left I
told the men to be careful because some
of the Chinese might still be alive it
was gruesome business but the only
solution to our most pressing problem
crawling over piles of dead Chinese the
smell was overpowering at time I could
hear gasp seep out of the decaying
corpses I could hear men behind me gag
and throw up yeah so this is like an
this is like you you've got to sit
around you've got a you gotta imagine
what this is like that they are vid
Chinese attackers are literally stacked
and piled on top of one another and
you're so low that you have to go out
and gather weapons and ammunition from
them and as you're doing that they're
bloated bodies are giving off gases and
it's that smells so horrible and the
whole scene is so horrific that your men
are dry heaving and throwing up as
you're trying to do this
back to the book for the rest of the
morning we passed out our new trove of
ammunition and dug in deeper as we
worked I heard the faint buzz of an
airplane overhead the spotter plane that
had dropped bags of medical supplies was
back so I skipped over this part but
there was a they got some medical
supplies from a little plane and this
time instead of dropping supplies it
dropped the message and this time the
pilot dropped it on target
guru Goro opened the message that's one
of the one of the other guys Goro
I hope I'm pronouncing that right gir oh
you ex guro open the message I saw the
caller leave his face I knew what the
message said before he told me we were
on our own no relief column was on its
way our new order was simple we needed
to get back to friendly lines the best
way we could
while Goro got the officers together I
gathered up a few of the sergeants and
we had a meeting well we are on our own
that message told us to get back the
best way we can I told the sergeants
Wallach was the first one to speak up we
can't just leave the wounded what the
hell else are we going to do a sergeant
I didn't recognize said the meeting was
tense I realized that what I had been
telling them was going to happen wasn't
going to no relief no rescue and if we
stayed in this hellhole we would all die
I don't think we didn't keep the Chinese
out of the perimeter for one for more
than one more night if we can even do
that I said there was silence we were
facing death but bravery is a funny
thing it comes in all shapes and sizes
and appears in men you at least expect
it from most of us didn't know one
another but we fought hard together like
we were blood brothers what do you say
about staying one more night maybe
somehow they'll break through to us
tomorrow I said
tomorrow we talk about the wounded
Wallach nodded his head and looked at
the others I'm for staying one more
night everyone quickly agreed no one
wanted to leave the wounded
I told grow the way the men felt and
after he meant with Brahms er male and
Peterson they all agreed no one was
comfortable leaving our wounded or the
wounded nearby in the battalion
headquarters the Chinese that night the
Chinese attacked three times and three
times we held but not without suffering
more casualties after the last attack I
literally fell into a hole near the
center of the perimeter I was fighting a
losing battle against sleep I could feel
myself slipping away my body felt numb
damp and heavy there was no noise no
sound I was paralyzed and the harder I
tried to move the more I felt the more
my body felt like stone I tried to
scream nothing
I tried harder I couldn't make a sound
bugles in the distance cleared my hazy
mind I could hear the burp burp of
Chinese submachine guns but the cup but
not the constant rattle of our own
machine gun closest to me I instantly
got a sick feeling I bolted out of the
trench and crawled toward the machine
gun position and fell into the hole
headfirst the gunner was wounded and the
assistant gunner was trying to put the
gun back into action
there was ammo but the gun was jammed I
racked it back nothing the head space
was screwed up the Chinese were the were
the the Chinese were within 20 yards of
us and I was screaming for the men to
keep firing I pulled the gun into the
hole and started to take it apart I
adjusted the head space put the barrel
and chamber in alignment and reassembled
it the a gunner
the assistant gunner laid the ammo belt
in and slapped the cover down I racked
the bolt back and pulled the trigger the
gun jumped back to life the fire
immediately had an impact and drove a
wedge into the advancing soldiers the
first book the first burst took out half
a dozen some of the wounded and dead
Chinese fell into our trenches others
crumbled in a heap near the edge close
enough that we could reach out and touch
them I looked down and saw that the
gunner was dead the a gunner was hit in
the arms and I could see blood staining
his fatigue jacket but he kept firing
his rifle and replacing ammo belts when
the machine gun went dry just as fast as
it started the attack ended there was
some sporadic firing from the other side
of the perimeter a couple of guys close
to the gun position came over to me and
took over as I headed back to my hole I
crawled over several dead American and
Chinese every trench and holes seemed to
be filled with wounded men screaming and
crying for their mothers always their
mothers
we had an added problem now since some
of the wounded wore Chinese soldiers the
dead were not a problem we just pushed
them out in front of the trench but the
wounded we had to help if we could the
medics did their best but we barely had
enough for own men the Chinese were all
scared to death crying and moaning they
were the enemy but they were also
soldiers just like us and it was
difficult to see them that way
the next morning bronzer and Goro called
me over to them the two artillery
lieutenants Mayo and Peterson were also
there Goro said what we all knew we
can't stay here any longer
there is no doubt in my mind that the
Chinese will overrun us tonight he said
we need to find a way out Willie will
you lead a Patrol lieutenants mayo and
Peterson have already volunteered to go
I looked at the lieutenant's and nodded
my head yes so they're gonna try and
find a way out of this perimeter and
they're going to do a little
reconnaissance tonight or now to try and
figure out their route so that then
later they can get out of there and come
up with a plan to get out of there back
to the book as we didn't so they're
crawling down a trench to try and look
for the way out as we crawl down the
trench toward the east side word got out
that we were going on Patrol Peterson
crawled by a badly wounded radio
operator lieutenant Peterson where are
you going looking for a way out he said
lieutenant Peterson
the radio operator pleaded please don't
leave me here please don't leave me you
can't leave me here for them to get me
Peterson looked shaken and I urged us
forward I heard him say he was sorry
as we crawled off others reached out to
us patted us on the back and wished us
good luck as we moved down the riverbed
the Chinese soldiers grabbed at us and
held out cops begging for water
I took my canteen and turned it upside
down to show them that we had no water
so there's the enemy they're also
wounded laying in these trenches it's
just a total bloodbath and the Chinese
soldiers are asking these Americans and
he can even imagine what these guys look
like at this point they've been fighting
for weeks on end they have no water
they've had no food they're out of
ammunition they're covered in blue
I mean Richardson's actually wounded and
a sorry state they're in
you got the Chinese soldiers that are
even worse State begging for water so
these guys find a route and I want to
make it sound like they found some easy
escape route that's gonna work they
found a possible way of getting out of
this perimeter and when they get back
they they come back and put out the word
like okay this is what we're gonna try
and do and to grow talk and he says we
move at 1700 before the Chinese move in
guro said word was passed to all
able-bodied men they were told to make
sure that they took what ammunition they
had left
I got a burp gun and some ammo
the wounded man knew what was happening
some broke down cried and begged us not
to leave please dear God take us one
soldier begged me grabbing at my shirt
don't leave us to the Chinese others
just watched in silence they knew they'd
slow us down
they also knew that they'd be dead soon
they simply asked that we come back for
them but I knew we were leaving them to
die or worse get captured
I knew my orders and agreed with them
but I couldn't shake the feeling that I
was leaving so many good men men who'd
fought well only to be left behind to
die
I wasn't sure I could ever forget this
this was the hardest thing I had done in
my short lifetime
this is your classic scenario of a what
do we do we do you know we leave no man
behind so then what's gonna happen if
they do that is everyone is going to die
and they make the decision now we could
have a theoretical debate on well maybe
if they fought it out maybe if they
stuck together maybe they could defeat
the Chinese that are surrounding them in
my estimation this is wrong
and you can see these guys already
stayed longer they've already done
everything that they can they're out of
ammunition they're surrounded by Chinese
the Chinese have unlimited number of men
that are literally in piles around them
and they know that if they are going to
if anyone is going to survive then they
need to make a break for it hmm and
again it's theoretical for us to do
sitting here it's hypothetical we could
say all we'd stay and fight we could say
whatever you want to say right now
you're not in that position
so now they leave at around five o'clock
they start making a move a few hours
into the march that rain turned into a
downpour in minutes we were soaked to
the skin the temperature was dropping
and started and I started to shiver
moving was the only way to stay warm I
pushed on trying to get as many miles as
possible between us and the old
perimeter we were well behind Chinese
lines and because of the size of our
group it was likely that we'd be spotted
soon now this is interesting
trying to move with I think they said
they had 80 able-bodied men maybe it's
60 that's a massive number of people you
can't hide 60 people it doesn't work you
can well I shouldn't say you can't it's
very very difficult to hide 60 people
like a platoon of 40 guys like it it's
hard you know in the SEAL Teams we have
little tiny elements too little tiny
platoons of 16 guys you can find some
terrain that will that will hide you we
just work in squads with 8 guys like ok
we can we can find a place to hide when
you have 60 or 80 guys behind enemy
lines that's gonna be a challenge I mean
just think about where can you hide that
many people like a perfect terrain
feature a ravine you know something like
that that's a lot of people to put new
ravine in just the noise discipline okay
well you know who's gonna COFF you get
60 people someone's gonna call I mean
just you and me sitting in this room and
we noticed when one of us costs because
or one one of us grunts or whatever
because we're recording it but you think
about what you know you and I sitting
here for two hours for three hours I
would say five times during that one of
us walk off right and you got to go edit
it out so if that's happening with two
of us you put 80 people into a ravine
where they're trying to hide from the
enemy and there's how many people are
coughing you know how many people are
sneezing right and it's not it's not
good odds and that's where these guys
are saying he is Richardson saying look
we have a massive group but it's not
gonna be easy to to hide
back to the book we need to get moving
to take advantage of the dark I left the
house they had been a little house
speaking of hiding I left the house
frustrated sergeant Mayer from the
battalions intelligence section called
me over let's get out of here he said
you and I have a better chance to get
back in this group is too large we don't
have the firepower to fight and they're
slowing us down so here's a guy's saying
look borough buses make a run for it he
was right I knew that we'd probably make
it back to friendly lines together
breaking down into smaller groups would
be better but I'd help Shepherd these
men too far to turn my back on them even
if it cost me my life
sorry can't do it mayor shrugged and
disappeared into the darkness so exactly
what I just said this guy made the
decision you know what now going alone
that's not a good idea there you know
cuz now you got no one to support you
you got no one to watch your six I mean
that's just a bad idea you can't even
need to sleep at some point and you're
by yourself what happens when you start
snoring right you know but this guy
figured I got a better chance of doing
this by myself so I'm gonna break out
now you could have given an order like
hey everyone there's something called
escape and invasion we're just
everyone's basically every man for
himself you could do that but at this
point Richardson is like hey we made it
this far we're gonna we're gonna stick
together
back to the book my group climbed to the
top of a knoll I could see the rounds
hitting a mountain no more than five
miles away we were closed for the first
time I felt hope then the hail erupted
with machine-gun and mortar fire I was
knocked flat on my face I quickly got up
and just as quickly got back down in the
prone position the Chinese were shelling
the hill my lower back felt wet and I
could feel what I thought was sweat
running down the crack of my ass
it wasn't sweat it was blood I was hit
but I didn't feel anything there was so
much smoke dirt and dust that I could
barely see I stumbled off the hill
followed by three others there were
about a dozen Chinese soldiers chasing
us i prodded myself too
think and move we started to head for a
village on the other side of the road
behind the village I could see a massive
rice paddy that ran up to a hill I
figured we could escape but if we got
over the hill first the paddy had about
three or four inches of water in it we
stayed on the tops of the dikes and God
halfway across the paddy before I turned
to fire back the Chinese soldiers douve
recover when they did we started running
again as I was running I saw rounds
hitting the water in front of me it's
not good when we got to the other side
we got down behind the dike and started
firing at the Chinese again I didn't see
anyone behind them if we could take them
out we had a chance but the others
didn't have any ammunition left and I
was down to a few rounds myself get
going I said I'll hold them off they
looked at me for a second go I screamed
and turned toward the Chinese soldiers
crossing the paddy I fired a few shots
and then douve behind a dyke a few
seconds later I fired two more bursts
before I was out of ammunition between
bursts my mind was searching for an
escape route I knew that if I ran
straight up the hill I didn't stand a
chance
about 30 yards to my right there was a
house a woman and a baby were crying and
wailing in a dugout near the hill I went
into the house if I went into the house
I was sure the woman would tell them but
I couldn't stay behind the dike with no
ammunition jumping up I ran behind the
house and started up the hill I tried to
keep the house in my back hoping to mask
my movement I went as far as I could go
without the Chinese seeing me and then
dove into a large bush rolling onto my
stomach with my Chinese burp gun
underneath me I waited I had no ammo but
I had a death grip on the weapon it was
like my security blanket I could hear
the Chinese soldiers climbing up the
hill they were yelling at one another I
was trying not to move
not even breathe
a fly hovered around my face landing on
my nose and mouth I tried to keep my
mind too close to everything I closed my
eyes as they passed and took my first
breath as I heard they're yelling behind
me in a few minutes I was sure they were
gone but every unit has one a straggler
that can't keep up
the Chinese straggler was so slow that
when he got close to the bush he saw me
I never moved and just shut my eyes he
started to holler to drove his bayonet
into my butt I felt the tip hit the bone
when I opened my eyes I saw boots all
around me my mind went to the burp gun
if I rolled over holding it they'd shoot
me for sure I shot my arms out along the
ground and rolled over leaving the burp
gun in the mud they reached down and
jerked me up
the barrel of the pistol looked like the
business end of a hundred and five
millimeter howitzer a Chinese officer
with red piping down the side of his
pants had the pistol pressed between my
eyes he was screaming at me in Chinese
and pointing up the hill I was numb and
couldn't speak I lifted my shoulders and
let them drop I thought of this moment
many times and I know that if he pulled
the trigger I would never have known it
that would have been the end I've been
captured now and I had no idea what to
do at least when I was on the run I knew
where I was going even fighting for my
life was easier than giving up all
control I was now at the mercy of the
Chinese so there you go captured just
fought until he's literally out of
ammunition and there's nothing else you
can do hmm nothing else he can do
ends up they must have some other guys
that got captured they must roam all
together now we're going back to the
book there are about ten Chinese guards
they lined up us they lined up beside us
and moved us down the road a couple
hundred yards suddenly the one in the
lead started yelling and the whole
column stopped the grass the guards
grabbed us and made us kneel down in
front of a ditch I could hear one of the
soldiers barking what sounded like
orders in Chinese my mind went on full
alert they were going to execute us I
felt the guy next to me shaking and
another started sobbing my god this is
it this is one of those situations where
you expect to see your life flash before
your eyes I was ready to relive relive
scenes from my childhood good times in
Austria anything to take my mind from
Korea and this ditch that didn't happen
to me I just closed my eyes
instead of shots I heard laughing they
motioned for us to get up the guy next
to me was so emotionally drained that he
couldn't get up I tried to help him but
my hands were tied behind my back get up
I yelled
don't let them laugh at you get up they
get to like a little building and they'd
been carrying captured rifles this whole
time so they get to a little building in
back to the book the Chinese dropped the
pile of rice on the ground and motioned
for us to eat it the prisoners rushed in
and started fighting over the grains I
staggered back from the melee and
angrily watched we've been turned into
animals after all we'd been through why
were why were the others not helping one
another instead they pushed and fought I
refused to join in we needed leadership
and control more than ever and I was
going to begin leading by example so
they go to they get some initial
interrogation of course you know that
mock execution horrible and then they
moves into the next chapter which is
called Death March
we started north up the road at a good
clip
the guards circled us like sharks sharks
pushing stragglers with their rifles
hitting and kicking anyone who stopped
many in the group were wounded one man
had a massive chest wound it was covered
by blood-stained bandages he wheezed as
he shuffled down the road my shoulder
was a little stiff and the shrapnel in
my back was wet and sticky but I felt
lucky it was nothing in comparison so
yeah next time you're thinking you have
a rough day how about you're a prisoner
of war on a death march and you've got a
massive chest wound
so now one of these some of the Chinese
could guards could speak English and
here we go pick up the wounded he kept
saying and like a broken record guard
started pushing us back toward the back
of the formation on the ground we're
about 20 soldiers on jerry-rigged
litters made out of burlap bags attached
and stretched between poles 10 more
soldiers stood around them pick up the
wounded the officer barked again it took
four of us to carry one litter I grabbed
the closest litter and hoisted it up the
soldier in the litter had a horribly
mangled leg his calf muscle was long
gone and his foot rested on the inner
limp on the litter of limp and lifeless
none of the wounded men had seen a
doctor since being captured I heard
someone say they'd been in trucks but
were dumped on the road when the trucks
were needed elsewhere a whistle sounded
and we started to shuffle toward the men
none of us were strong enough to carry
the stretchers very long my shoulders
burned I tried to focus on each step
left right left right whenever things
got tough my won't mind wandered back to
the guy with the sucking chest wound or
I stole a glance at the guy on the
litter with a mangled leg I vowed to
never quit but soon my body started to
break down I tried to get another
prisoner to relieve me but everyone I
asked looked away or moved ahead most
hid in the dark trying to stay as far
away from the stretchers as they could
you son of a [__] I barked at one
soldier who almost jerked away when I
asked I was disgusted it reminded me of
the soldiers that first night fighting
over the rice we'd forgotten that the
backbone of any military was the bond of
the soldiers we fought for the guys to
our left and right that is why we fought
to protect our unit buddies and we
expected them to do the same but on a
death march every man was an island
there seemed to be no place for anything
else I refused to be that way
it's a heavy burden each night the
guards were getting tougher they were
constantly pushing and hitting men with
the rifles if a man fell behind he was
shot and pushed off the mountainside
everyone was rapidly losing weight
lack of food wounds and disa dysentery
were taking their toll
carrying the men on stretchers was
becoming even more difficult we looked
like skeletons our uniforms hung off us
like a scarecrow is quote coat each time
we got topped each time we top one of
the mountains we faced another one ears
nose fingers and toes were becoming numb
at times I felt like I was walking on my
ankles I was lucky that my legs had
always been the strongest part of my
body many of the wounded men who were
strong enough to walk earlier were now
in the need of stretchers however there
were none and we found ourselves
carrying them along between two of us in
some cases we are practically dragging
them when I heard a single rifle shot
back down the road I knew another man's
struggle was over my heart was aching
for them but at the same time my mind
kept telling me to move we had two
choices march or die
my survival mode kicked in not allowing
me to surrender to pain and fatigue
the guards shoved us into a cluster of
huts so after walking a long time they
get to get to like a little village we
were jammed into the room so tightly
that my legs rested on another soldier
the only thing good about sleeping this
way was that we were warmer a cold front
from the plains of Manchuria came
roaring down and slamming into the very
mountains we were struggling through we
were facing the coldest winter in 50
years as we got ready to move out the
commander of the guards told us to leave
the stretchers the wounded were pleading
with us to take them I started to move
toward one and got a rifle but in the
gut others tried to grab the stretchers
but the guards pushed them away too I
started to move toward the helpless
soldiers again but couldn't risk another
blow I let my mind drift into a zombie
State hoping to block out the screams of
the wounded left foot right foot left
foot right foot over and over again I
repeated it until I couldn't hear their
screams
yeah
absolutely horrible just absolutely
horrible after 10 nights we marched into
a fairly good-sized town and this is
when he decides that he's gonna try to
escape pretty early on and he's got a
couple buddies and there's some
confusion and there's some chaos that
that happens as they're trying to round
up the prisoners and he kind of jumps
over with a couple of the guys into a
little ditch and they cover up with some
branches and they start talking these
three guys start saying look what you
know can we make a move well let's you
know let's head south and then finally
one of the guys says that would be
suicide in our condition we won't make
it over those mountains
we don't have warm clothes and we will
probably die of hypothermia we knew he
was right it was smarter to wait until
springtime we needed to try and survive
and hope our forces liberated us now
they're starting to get into like a
little bit of a routine my goal is to
bring back discipline and start acting
like soldiers again the scene the first
night with the rice dropped on the
ground was burned into my brain the only
way we could survive until spring was
and a possible escape attempt was to
start working together
the second wound had suffered the most
are frostbitten feet had turned to
trench foot and open wounds were
infected or gangrene and said in for
those guys it was only a matter of time
before they died since we had no
medicine to treat them and finally from
his little group he loses a guy whose
last name is graves graves was the first
to die the valley had turned into one of
death and suffering
soon after graves death chaplain Kapaun
came to the house we were all surprised
to see him I had last seen him at Osan
but when he walked and I barely
recognized him the man I'd met on a
region Pusan was gone he'd lost a lot of
weight and his uniform kind of hung on
his frame his tired and worn-out eyes
bolide his warm smile
Kapaun told us who was dead or wounded
before he left
he told us to get organized we'll need
to take action when the troops show up
he said have a plan when the troops get
close the North Koreans might try to
kill us all Kapaun never came back to my
house but he continued to visit troops
in the valley I know he prayed for each
one of us when he could brought food to
the starving until he became so weak
that the guards took him to the hospital
that we're gonna hear about what that
hospital consisted of he died of
pneumonia in May of 1951 it was buried
in a mass grave by the Yalu River and if
you don't know the story about chaplain
Kapaun he was awarded the Medal of Honor
for his actions in the Korean War then
I'm sure we'll cover that in more detail
at some point on this podcast but in the
meantime you can look it up and read
about a hero of war and a hero of faith
at one point
Richardson tries to steal some kimchi
and again now I'm fast-forwarding a bit
to where to where there a little bit
more settled in and he he steals like a
bowl of kimchi and they started the
guards call nuts and they're trying to
find out who took the kimchi who took
the kimchi and they threaten them with
hey no one's gonna be able to eat until
we know who took the kimchi and finally
he breaks down and says I did it only me
now was the officers turned to shake his
head
you lie more do it no only me and the
guards I said the little son of a [__]
looked at me and then nodded to the
guards who grabbed me and tied my arms
behind my back you learn lesson now the
officer said the guards threw a rope
over an open truss and pulled me up by
my arms until my feet barely touched the
dirt floor the pain was excruciating
I could feel lightning jolts of pain in
my left arm and shoulder where I still
had shrapnel wounds the pain quickly
crept up my arms driving straight to the
top of my head I gasped for air the
pressure on my chest allowed me to take
only sharp short breaths I could hear
myself moaning and once I cried out in
pain before I passed out I woke up on
the dirt floor I could barely feel the
guards pulling the ropes off my arms I
could hear the son-of-a-bitch rattle off
a few a few orders he sounded far away
but I could see his boot ii knew he was
standing over me the guards dragged
means my feet throwing open the door
that tossed me on the floor of my room I
could barely move my legs and arms and
stayed where I landed the rest of the
night Martin helped me get comfortable
and told me that the house had been fed
earlier that night he had no idea how
long I'd been strung up the next morning
i sat up and started making jokes some
of them laughed with me others were just
scared
laughing hurt my ribs but it was the
first time I've done it since you saw I
was determined to keep my sense of humor
I was tied it was tied to my will to
live from that point on I remember to
laugh whenever I could well I guess we
won't be having kimchee anymore
after two months in the valley the
guards marched us out of the valley and
back up to the road in Pew Tong so
they're in a different location now and
in this location the Chinese finally
full fully take over the operation of
the camp as opposed to the the Koreans
the North Koreans so now the it seems
like the Chinese were a little bit nicer
to the prisoners
the Chinese issued each of us a small
drinking cup along with a bowl for our
millet or our maize no more eating out
of a helmet liner we were also allowed
to start a cook house for each company
and we were occasionally given soybeans
the wells were contaminated from animal
and human feces seeping through the
ground and into the water well so we
didn't have fresh water there were about
3,000 men in the camp conditions were
about as bad as a human being could
possibly live with so again I pointed
out that the Chinese were a little bit
nicer because they gave them like a bowl
but it's a don't get me wrong this was
about as close as you could get to
Andersonville in the Civil War which
that was a Confederate prisoner of war
camp of for Union soldiers and there was
about 45,000 soldiers that were captured
and that were in that prison camp about
13,000 of them died from scurvy and from
from diarrhea and dysentery so you know
it's funny we think of like diarrhea
first of all we think of it's like a
joke and then we think of as like an
inconvenience but when you're in these
situations it kills you hmm
back to the book we were full of lice
the farm boys told us we were they were
hog lice growing larger every day on our
blood while the lice got fat we starved
the guards brought us two bowls of
millet a day and one bowl of boiled
water which barely kept us alive
and even when we ate dysentry kept us
weak and dehydrated hunger can do some
strange strange things to your mind I
was at the latrine a slit trench and I
noticed that many of the soybeans were
passed whole I thought if I picked them
out of the feces and wash them off I
could eat them then it dawned on me that
I must be going crazy or turning into an
animal it would be a few days before I
was able to get over the fact that I had
let myself sink to a disgusting thought
like that
so next time you're feeling hungry
you're not feeling hungry you even know
what that feels like they ended up like
forming a little group he just mentions
this this one guy in this group named
Vincent Doyle Doyle became the leader of
this little group an infantryman during
World War two he had a wife and a son in
Fall River River Massachusetts he
received a battlefield commission in
France and left the army as the
lieutenant he opened up a frozen food
store in Fall River a little ahead of
its time not many families had freezers
he went out of business and re enlisted
as a master sergeant not an officer he
was an inch too short to be an officer
the army told him yeah that's one of the
reasons why I left that and there's like
the guys just humble like oh I can't cut
it as an officer anymore even though I
got a battlefield commission in World
War two oh that's okay I'll just do I'll
just enlist that's known for no factor
that's that's like the humility but if
you see that kind of humility anymore
normally I don't make a big deal out of
the generational differences but that's
a pretty humble guy right there
back to the book our biggest problem was
our physical condition brought on by the
March men with open wounds many with
gangrene didn't survive long some were
saved from gangrene by maggots eating
their dead flesh which only meant they
suffered longer no we've been through
that before with the Forgotten Islander
who they would actually put maggots to
get rid of dead flesh to try and save
themselves some of the soldiers had
black feet from frostbite and trench
foot I watched while one man pulled
rotted flesh off his toe bones the
soldiers from the 2nd Infantry Division
had it worst they'd been issued shoe
packs rubber boots with felt liners and
insoles their feet would sweat and they
were continuously wet while marching and
they would freeze when they stopped
marching since they never took off the
shoe packs the soldiers got trench foot
it's easily understood when men
of wounds or pneumonia it is more
difficult to understand when men just
lie down and quit I've seen strong men
seemingly just give up and die first
they would stop eating and stare with
blank eyes at the mud walls of the hut
their minds were gone and life just
slipped away then after a few days you
heard an all-too-familiar death rattle
we were dying at a rate of about 30 a
day each morning we took out the dead
stripped him of their clothes and
stacked them like cordwood in a pile at
first we tried to take the uniforms and
coats and give them to other prisoners
but the Chinese guards wouldn't allow it
what they did with the uniforms is still
a mystery I hated being part of the
burial detail the physical part was bad
enough but the mental part was much
worse thoughts about the families of the
dead men and if they left children
behind who might never know what
happened to them I knew from listening
to men talk that what bothered most of
them was the thought that they might be
next that's one thing I never let my
mind to think about
and again he moves around a bit to
various places and various camps and
gets various jobs and again you have to
read this book to really comprehend this
the level of suffering that was endured
by these prisoners back to the book in
early spring 1951 the Chinese were
building small docks on the river and I
was unlucky enough to be put to work on
the crew a group of us were carrying one
of these Timbers up a hill when someone
in the center stumble stumbled and the
timber fell pinning me to the ground and
when that happens his back gets jammed
up and and even though he makes it
through that day it starts getting worse
and worse throughout the day now there's
a hospital right it's a hospital but
they actually called this hospital it's
just like every other prisoner camp that
we've heard about when you go to the
hospital you're dead that's just a place
they put you to die and it's the same
thing here so his guys are trying to
prevent him from being taken to the huh
to the hospital so they're carrying him
back and forth to their formations and
finally the Chinese realized that he
can't walk so the Chinese come to the
door and back to the book they were
taking me to the hospital we called it
the morgue we had never seen anyone
return from there I wanted to fight back
but I couldn't the guards closed the
door to one of the rooms in the cluster
of houses that served as the hospital
and threw me in it was dark and I could
not see anyone I landed on top of a
wounded and sick lying on the dirt floor
they immediately started kicking and
cursing me the stench from the wounds
and the human feces was unimaginable I
started to gag so this is I mean this is
just the daughter you can't even imagine
anything is food gonna be worse than the
situation is and now he's put in this
reliant room filled with [__] and
wounded people that are going to die and
by the way it's like they've got
dysentery and they've got diarrhea so
it's just a total nightmare and he's
trying to maintain a little bit of
dignity and he asks one of the guys in
where's the where's the latrine he had
to use the restroom and the guy tells
him out the door go left to the end of
the building left again in 25 yards on a
knoll you'll find the latrine the
temperature was freezing but I welcome
the fresh air I dragged myself out on my
buttocks pushing myself along with my
hands I reached the latrine a trench a
foot and a half wide and ten feet long
the trench sat just outside a strand of
wire that separated our camp from the
black prisoners the human waist was like
pudding and almost reached to the top of
the trench I managed to get my pants
down and had worked my way to the edge
when the side caved in I fell into the
trench finally catching my shoulders on
the edge the waist was at my chin as I
clawed at the dirt trying to pull myself
free my legs paralyzed like an anchor
pulled me toward the bottom I yelled out
and kept crawl clawing
but every second I slipped deeper and
deeper into the trench two black
prisoners on the other side heard me
they crawled through the barbed wire
grabbed me by my arms and pulled me out
a second later and I would have slipped
under the surface
the guards heard all the commotion and
were closing in
my saviors scrambled back through the
fence just as the guards arrived to this
day I have no idea who saved me fearing
I was trying to escape they started to
beat me with the rifle butts
I covered my head to try and protect
myself as I lay there covered and [__] I
lost control of my bowels that was it I
was done but giving up meant deaf
I had lived with death everyday since
coming to Korea the battlefield was like
a movie and fast forward there wasn't so
much going on and I couldn't dwell on
death very long call from the medic
possibly hold the wounded man in my arms
or say a word or two as he passed from
life to death it was different as a
prisoner I had no way of defending
myself other than using my mind and what
physical capabilities I could muster I
realized my mind had to be my strength
for a split second all of the pain and
suffering could have ended No my mind
screamed I could not give up I'd come
this far and in that second I set my
mind to doing something no one had done
I was going to come back from the morgue
as the Chinese soldiers landed blow
after blow on my back and legs i
banished death from my mind never again
did it enter into it
many lost control of their minds and did
things they would never have done under
normal circumstances I didn't know what
to say when I heard stories or saw
things where men were mistreating one
another I thought of the first night of
captivity when the Chinese dumped the
rice on the ground what happens to men
when they become prisoners why did they
change from helping one another and
becoming and become totally engrossed in
themselves with totally selfish outlook
on life understand I'm not talking about
all men but many never come to grips of
losing their freedom they feel abandoned
by their country and are no longer
longer with men they trust in their
minds their personal survival becomes
paramount and group survival no longer
matters so again I mean going back to
that part at the latrine that's a little
that's a little footnote you can put in
your brain for the rest of your life
because we're all gonna have bad
situations I get it I mean there's gonna
be horrible things that are gonna happen
I don't know if there's much I don't
know if it can get much worse than the
situation that he was in right there and
and realizing that his mind was his
strength realizing that he had no other
way to defend but his mind had to be
strong and he had that little split
second thought that he could give up and
just let it all go just let it all go
let that pain and suffering stop but
then he realized no not gonna do that
not going to surrender not happening
so eventually I mean he goes through
more hell and eventually gets on a to
crutches and then one crutch and
eventually he makes it he makes it out
of the morgue then he gets sent back
with the rest of the rest of the team
and when he gets better they're like
completely amazed this is a guy that
they they probably mourned his death
because they thought when you go to the
morgue you're dead and when he gets back
he's with Doyle and smoke these are his
boys Doyle and smoke SM okay welcome
back Doyle said says no one had ever
come back from the morgue the guys
peppered me with questions about his
treatment what treatment I said and they
all laughed I told them we never
received any medicine got less food in
the room smelled like a cesspool I told
them how I'd almost drown in the trench
and that two guys from the black
compound saved my life it was a shitty
situation I said and again they all
laughed so this guy does a great job of
trying to keep keep track of that humor
continuing since I've been in the morgue
the Chinese had started putting a lot of
pressure on us we were required to spend
hours and lectures and discussion groups
supervised by Chinese political officers
this is when the indoctrination has
taken place don't you explain that the
political officers began by breaking you
down physically so you started to agree
with them and then just just to get them
off your back when this happened they
would be on you full force pushing you
to make a statement against the United
States government or to make a statement
as to the next wonderful treatment that
you're receiving next you'd be one of
the turncoats standing up on stage
giving a lecture so they're going
through this even though they're getting
trying to get propaganda statements out
of them they're still getting treated
horribly we were still dying in great
numbers it has just been removed from
our sight they also tried to improve our
diet prisoners even started to make
steamed bread by taking balls of dill
and placing them on a bamboo
go for a pot of steaming water and one
of the one of the leaders I just had to
note this one one of the interrogation
propaganda communist leaders said I will
leave a hundred men to die to save one
progressive meaning communist and they
spoke English those are the words that
they used the Chinese interrogators
propaganda people who spoke English and
he says we outwardly challenge the loss
of individual freedom under their system
the Chinese became quite agitated and I
like this part so there again I mean I
want to say that they're getting the
treatments good by any stretch but it's
at least a little bit better and it's
part of it is them trying to convince
them to you know beat communists so they
can make statements against American do
that whole thing so they here's here's
this one part despite working many hours
building the longhouses
we were still required to attend lakh
lectures and once a child it was their
version of a USO show called the white
haired girl the storyline was simple a
peasant family could not pay the taxes
demanded by the dastardly landowner so
he takes the peasants beautiful young
black haired daughter as his concubine
she suffers terribly under his demented
date demands but eventually escapes to
the mountains years later as the
people's libera libera army frees the
people the girl returns to the village
but now her hair has turned completely
white the play was well done and the
Chinese officers and soldiers hung on
every word they saw the girl's story as
their own they clapped when the People's
Liberation Army arrived the play of
course omitted the fact that Mao had
killed thousands and I'll correct him
there millions of people and his drive
to take control of China and this is why
I read this part cuz he says we laughed
and cheered when the landlord dragged
the young girl away
the Chinese guards were not amused and
for days there was an awkward silence I
kinda got a kick out of that
a bunch of rambunctious prisoners of war
ruining your little play when I got warm
enough the Chinese let us stakeout a
baseball field near the river we didn't
have any balls or bats but we went
through the motions we made teams and
selected umpires we called balls and
strikes it sounded weird but we had a
lot of fun we spent hours out there and
then he goes on to tell this story late
one afternoon I got when I read that I
was like that's kind of interesting I
mean I could see we'd do something to
entertain yourself but they had a little
bit of a bigger plan
late one afternoon a lone American
fighter jet came screaming down the
river we were out on the ball field at
first it scared the hell out of us and
went by us in a flash but doubled back
and flew straight down the river we
could see the pilot looking down and as
he passed the pilot waved and wiggled
his wings at us there were no words to
describe how that incident made us feel
god bless him he probably never knew
that's what that simple act did for us
it was very long time before we stopped
talking about it and we'd achieved our
goal with the ball field
the Chinese refused to identify POWs
camps but the ball field did the trick
yeah
soon after wet winter set in so now
they're going another winter I got sick
started running a high fever was
coughing up green and yellow mucus toil
and smoke moved me near the stove and
kept me hydrated with hot water a medic
told me I had pneumonia
I thought of graves and was grateful
that I wasn't still in the morgue after
a couple days that favor the fever broke
and I got better
Doyle and smoke both said they were sure
I'd make it yeah yeah rich some of us
thought we might need to dip you in the
[__] again to make you matters what
smoked all them in early spring my legs
were finally in shape to begin thinking
about escape again when I read that I
just wrote the words long game next to
it I mean bro
can you imagine you're three years deep
in prison camp and the whole time you're
thinking well if I can just take the
next year to get my legs healed up
enough where I can walk then I can try
and escape again
he when he first got captures like okay
if I can just make the springtime will
be a little bit stronger let the weather
just talk about playing the long game
they as they were planning this escape
they were gonna take Doyle and smoke and
they were talking about it and soon
smoke was doubled over
Doyle tried to get the Chinese to do
something but they ignored us please
soon smoke couldn't talk he just lay in
bed and moan when it got really bad he
screamed finally he passed out his face
was locked in a torn tortured grimace
and his skin turned ashen at noon the
medical that was helping him turn to us
and shook his head he's dead the words
landed on us like mortar rounds I just
stood there staring at his face and
shocked dead how could this have
happened in such a short time only seven
months ago men were dying all around us
it was normal since we moved prisoners
didn't die anymore we were the survivors
this wasn't supposed to happen to anyone
anymore the shock quickly boiled up into
a rage
and these guys kind of you know kind of
yell at the Chinese and you make a
little they they kind of cause some some
problems nothing too drastic but you
know they weren't they weren't just
cowering anymore hmm
back to book the winter of 1952 to 53
was livable compared to the past two
winters we were allowed to select our
own leaders and organize committees to
work on different facets of our daily
life a sanitation committee athletic
committee a daily action committee all
brought some semblance of order to our
lives food had improved too we got
steamed bread vegetables and rice once
in a while some fish and meat but it was
usually just a scrap the change in diet
was enough to let us gain some weight
July 27th 1953 the Chinese had us all in
a formation when they announced that a
peace agreement had been reached we
stood silently looking at one another no
one said anything this news had been a
long time coming I just stood there a
smile plastered across my face I looked
down at my rail thin frame like a map it
showed my journey scars on my back from
shrapnel a missing tooth night blindness
from lack of vitamins which luckily only
lasted for a couple of weeks I was one
of the fortunate ones I'd survived and
that's in it I mean that's like it like
it just changes immediately now they
still have to get out of there to this
day when I think of our movement south I
still get butterflies in my stomach they
were moving us to the railhead at mam PO
the Chinese gave one of the prisoners a
lock and told him to close the gates
after the trucks pulled out after we
passed he snapped the lock shut closing
some of the darkest chapters in my life
and they continue this trains planes and
automobiles to try and get to freedom we
boarded that finally we get to we
boarded the trucks and proceeded to
cross the freedom bridge to freedom
village when we arrived I didn't wait
for the tailgate to drop I jumped right
out onto the ground there were two
American escorts for each of us they
grabbed me and I thought holy [__] these
guys were big and muscular I quickly
realized they were average guys I was
just a little skinny and at one point he
gets on a scale he weighed a hundred and
eight pounds our first stop was tent
city in a thousand-yard neutral circle
in the rice paddies we stripped we
stripped showered and deloused having
put on slippers and pyjamas we were
checked by good-looking nurses we stayed
less than an hour before we moving to
another building to get uniforms and our
first meal after our meal we were flown
by helicopter to a replacement Depot
Ninh Shan it was my first helicopter
flight and I sat near the door and
watched Korea pass in a blur below me I
felt like screaming singing and dancing
but instead I remained subdued quiet and
happy inside fifty-seven years had
passed and I can still remember how
great it felt like being born again then
he gets on the phone and he says I reach
my dad I could hear the excitement in
his voice he bombarded me with questions
are you alright when are you coming home
don't worry about me I'll be okay
there was some kind of calmness inside
of me that was difficult to describe
I've been through so much that just
being free and headed home was enough
after worrying about living day in and
day out
I wondered if anything would ever bother
me in the future the voyage back to
California on the Brewster which was the
ship they were on was great they served
three meals a day
the small things mattered more now than
before we were subjected to daily
debriefings which were more like
interrogations by intelligence officers
he goes through answered a bunch of
questions about what he saw and what he
went through and they were actually
trying to figure out if they were more
like how many other prisoners were there
other prisoners that were left behind
he finishes those and those
interrogations are those questioning or
Intel gathering situations and then for
the rest of the voyage I stayed on the
deck I sucked in the fresh sea air and
bashed in the warm breeze everything I
could hear smell and see was so full of
life as I looked over the rail of the
ship I remembered three years ago
looking down at the sea and praying that
I would have the strength to lead my men
in combat now I was returning by myself
I'd been born again a chance to live for
tomorrow to make the most of every day
and never look back I had survived the
greatest laboratory of human behavior
one that no education could ever equal
weeks later the Golden Gate Bridge
gutted out of the fog as the ship pulled
into port we had a few hours before our
flight so I left and walked around the
post my path took me to the post
cemetery it was very quiet and my
thoughts were on all of the men and
Friends
that were no longer with me Walsh the
ROE smoked I could feel them standing
above me I hope they were smiling and
happy for me because it was my men my
section that had kept me motivated and
alive I owed my freedom and survival to
them a number of us flew to Chicago
where we changed planes when the plane
left Chicago I was the only returning
prisoner of war aboard although the
plane was full of people I felt very
lonely I was free and on my way home
with mixed emotions
realize that I just left men that I had
lived with 24 hours a day for 34 months
it was sad then with all the freedom
surrounding me that there was an empty
feeling
there were also thoughts of the ones who
would never return the ones whose lives
had been lost almost before they began
when we landed in Philadelphia the
stewardess asked if we would remain
seated for just a minute while a special
passenger exited the plane to my
surprise that special passenger was me I
walked down the stairs and onto the
tarmac waiting there where my mother and
father they hugged and kissed me this
time unlike on the street before the war
I realized the act of affection between
father and son was a wonderful thing and
I will never forget the emotion on my
father's face as tears welled up in his
eyes and he goes on and there is a whole
story within a story within a story in
this about a woman that was an associate
a friend and and and several others and
there was there's a whole other realm to
this but he gets you know he starts to
get back on with his life a little bit
back to the book while I was absorbing
the sounds and sights of freedom I was
beginning to think about my future I had
been given a second chance and was
determined that I was not going to blow
it Claire and I had become inseparable
and I was falling in love with her
my only fear was that the feeling might
not be mutual we had a wonderful
Christmas holiday and both realize that
we were definitely meant to be together
during a New Year's Eve party
I gave Claire an engagement ring she
said yes we announced to everyone that
we were going to be married there were
happy people sad people and mad people
to tell the story behind this statement
would take another book but five
children and fifty-six years later we're
still happily married and from there and
this is this is like as I was you know
researching this whole situation this is
so he gets done with this and he ends up
going to Officer Candidate School in the
army he gets assigned to the 551
Infantry Regiment that's fine
awesome of just outstanding and then he
then he goes to Special Forces
at Fort Bragg North Carolina and so he's
you know becomes a green beret special
forces guy and then he goes to Vietnam
and he is the two-time commander of
project Delta in Vietnam which is like
the the the deep reconnaissance like the
the the the the format like this is how
we do deep reconnaissance is based on
project Delta and project Delta has also
had Beckwith and it Charlie Beckwith who
is the the founder of Delta Force so you
know Richardson just drives on and does
deployments to Vietnam going into enemy
territory deep in enemy territory mm-hm
and ends up doing 39 years in the army
and and you know like you said has you
know the wife and the kids and the
incredible career and after that you
know we had us it has a civilian he's
still alive by the way yeah then here's
what he closes out with he says every
day on this journey I believed the men
of the weapons platoon and my close
buddies in prison were watching me to
see how I looked after my men and
prepared them for whatever they may have
had to face I tried my best
to make them proud of me so well I think
that Colonel Richardson I think we can
absolutely answer in the affirmative
that yes I think anyone would be proud
of how you handled yourself how you led
and then on top of that how you lived
your life I mean I think that's just
self-evident in every page of this book
which once again valleys of death his
unbelievable book should be handed out
to people it should be issued in the
military as far as I'm concerned and I
mean I think in reading the book I mean
it's like your actions
Colonel Colonel Richardson's actions his
behavior I mean how can you not be how
can you not think to yourself that you
can do a little bit better with the
situation that you're in and realize how
much people are how much human beings
are capable of I don't I just don't I
don't see how you could read this and
not walk away and say you know what I'm
gonna do better
and whatever situation you're in look
and I know people who end up in horrible
situations but no matter what that
situation is no matter what it is you
can you can move forward you can move
forward you can keep your mind positive
you can use your mind as your weapon and
also you can you know one of the parts
in that's encompassed and that is like
oh you can actually have have fun and
keep your sense of humor when you're
going through these terrible situations
which people ask me that all the time
like don't you do you think it's
important to have a sense of humor of
like of course I do you know of course I
do
but again Colonel Richardson if you ever
hear this obviously there is a wide open
invite for you to come and debrief us
and teach us life lessons here and tell
us about tell us more detail and the
parts that I know I missed and things
that I messed up I apologize but thanks
thanks for your service thanks for your
sacrifice and thanks for showing us
[Music]
showing us how to live properly even in
the most dire of circumstances with that
tells oh yeah I was reading this book
and it was just I couldn't I couldn't
stop and I couldn't stop
I couldn't stop it's one of those books
you just don't you just don't see it's
it's so hard to understand like some of
that combat the beginning is crazy
mm it's crazy just the situation that
they were in I mean you're surrounded by
the Chinese for three days and they're
just a hammering your perimeter all
night with waves human waves and then
you get the note drop from a point from
a damn plane that says no relief is
coming find your way out hmm
appreciate it yeah and then you got to
leave you wounded that's that's what
happens it's like okay we either all die
really this is just like it's incredible
yeah it's incredible and you should read
this so you get some sort of semblance
of maybe what your thoughts are gonna be
when you if you get into a situation
like that whatever it is hmm so yeah
always learning always and for me again
I get done with this and I can't even
sleep because I think to myself I got so
much opportunity as I guess what oh I
wake up and I'm I can walk around I
don't have shrapnel in my back yeah I
get to eat food whatever you like yeah
whatever you want
there's a natural like we like people
complain about working out you complain
like no I don't feel like working what
are you talking about I got a good idea
once you just be quiet just stop people
complain that they gotta go to work
guess what your blast you're lucky you
get to go to work yeah you're lucky best
thing about that yesterday that working
out thing I like people complain only
cuz my arm you know you have your
situations that keep you from working
out or training yeah
and on the up like did you check
yourself when you get it well it was a
moment of appreciation or what it was
but you know when you get you know you
get injured or sick and you feel
yourself getting better and I call shoot
like I'm mark you know like today I felt
better than I've felt this whole time
kind of thing that's when the waves of
appreciation you come back come back
come back you know what the thing is
also for those people that you know when
you get an injury you think it's gonna
last forever
this one it feels like oh it feels like
forever and then you realize when you
get back you kind of forget that it even
happened yeah yeah so yeah so the eating
and that's a big part every time he
mentions um eating or starving or all
the weight that he lost and 108 pounds
yeah so that for whatever reason those
that affects me a lot when I hear it
it's like oh man cuz you picture your
biceps well you know just being hungry
the whole time you know yeah like yeah
what's so long as you fasted for like 24
hours like a you need to get your 72 oh
no I don't know cuz you're you're saying
for me cuz cuz being hungry goes away
after a while yeah yeah I haven't done I
haven't done hunger for thirty four
months yeah well it goes away like after
like seven hours
I think our sides like to me in my
experience it depends on you who you are
I'm sure but at about 4-5 hours that's
when that's peak hunger again in my
experience but either way so you know
when he gets back like he you know I
can't even believe wait just so everyone
knows we are in no stretch of the any
sort of imagination trying to compare a
fast for 24 hours with 34 months thirty
four months and I mean look at look at
captain plum six years then I know
Hilton eating rice ball in the morning
in a rice ball in the evening with
filled with woodchips what's up wood
chips you know what you go to a
restaurant right now if your rice is
like slightly overcooked you're
complaining or just back yeah nevermind
bugs and wood chips in that yeah no no
it's typically no yeah it's yeah that's
that's rough to say the least but now
you know and I look I'm living you know
we're living kind of this journey with
him in a small way right and he the
piece you know they come to you know
peace agreement so he's back on the boat
feeling the warm air eating three times
a day man it makes you think like now
okay what 2018 right but there's like
there's more than one to there's many
many apps on your phone
mmm that you can be like hey I want a
triple burger double cheese bacon bacon
avocado and you know what onions grilled
onions and I'm gonna need that grass-fed
yeah oh yeah I'm kind of steak isn't
quite good enough unity over here so and
by the way can I get the what's the
special kind of mayonnaise that has like
something else in it well there's a few
thousand a aoao a only man is because
that other normal man isn't quite in
your you know I need to stop at all we
just don't want that yeah we don't we
don't we want the good one so haha and
so let me go ahead and click this button
so spoiled yeah and then it comes to
your door oh yeah about 15 somebody
brings there in 15 minutes to drive
seven and it's if it's 22 minutes you're
kind of mad
kind of death like you know I was hungry
you know you know that and it'll say 10
to 20 to 1 on that like people people
they get separated from their phone and
they freak out right I mean you imagine
this like what you would even know yeah
what what's happening anything in the
world
you know nothing you know nothing of
what's happening in the world with your
family yeah nothing yeah yeah so with
this since other people have suffered
through that maybe in in our world you
can you can try and get yourself on a
little bit better of a path with a
little bit more discipline in the world
is what I'm saying yeah I know I need to
step it up harder you know to do more
trying to make more stuff happen yeah
cuz the opportunities there think about
you know and the crazy thing is
Richardson's one of the people that
survived because there's thousands upon
thousands that didn't that died of
diarrhea that died of dysentery that
died of gangrene and infections yeah so
man we got it made
so you know what we got it made so make
something how's that sound
we got it made so make something of what
you got which is everything which is
everything by the way unless you're in a
next - unless you're drowning in a
trench full of [__] a hundred and eight
pounds with no with your legs not
working with scars in your back unless
you're in that situation how about you
step up and die just start moving in the
right direction do a little we're doing
all right
yeah and in the helpful or what makes it
helpful is like perspective right when
you put it into perspective let's say
you live in your life every day gyro
used to it we're all used to it and you
don't feel like doing something that's
really what it what it comes down to and
of course there's different levels of
not feeling like doing something it's
like kind of not feeling like judgement
or hey that this is straight I'm not
gonna happen today kind of feel it not
if you like doing something so when you
put it into perspective I don't know if
you can like right it's like no it's a
not our it's not argument exactly right
even if it doesn't hold zero water
whatsoever exactly right you can't get
to a place that you don't feel like you
can't convince me ever that whatever
you're saying is is even remotely weighs
in on the situation at all ever
exactly right that's where I don't want
to know whatever yeah when you know it
needs to get done and you don't feel
let's say it man I haven't slept in two
days let's say that that's legitimate in
everyday life like man you get your ass
bro oh yeah but if it needs to be done
after you read this book let's say you
didn't sleep because you read that book
and this up for two days you really
don't feel like going to the gym I'll
tell you that physically but leaving it
back to just going and doing a bicep
workout whatever you know but I hope
people want I hope people as a bare
minimum I hope people use them the
mindset you can pull from the from the
perspective you get from this I hope at
a bare minimum you get your workouts at
the maximum I hope you step up and just
take over the world yeah cuz it's
sitting there right in front of you yeah
you're not locked behind barbed wire and
you don't have your arms strong up
behind your back getting hung from the
ceiling so painful that you pass out so
hateful that you pass out which that's
just what does that even mean it means
you can kind of do anything really when
when you kind of put into perspective so
so what are we doing me and Dave Burke
good deal tea yes yes but you know what
he does reads a lot of books too and he
just like man we didn't we just suck
yeah I'm like yeah it's just you can't
even know like I sent him a note I was
wanting to know I said hey you had
combat you did combat flights in
Afghanistan and Iraq and he's like he's
like bro come on you know that's just
come on and I'm like well he's like yeah
ten I technically did I drop bombs in
those countries yes was where they
considered combat operations I'm like
yeah and he's like put come on music
he's like I got two words for you Iwo
Jima and I was like all right I get it
oh yeah that's that's how you feel when
you get done or something cuz and then
but by the way he's got a 1 1/2 of a
paragraph where he's like oh by the way
I did 39 years in the army and by the
way I was in Vietnam and by the way I
was in charge of project Delta for
two times twice yeah it's not like a
little sub that's like a little little
something like it's just a little sub
nope
yeah no PS the PostScript yeah geez talk
about that should be its own book each
one of those command tours is its own
book about doing deep reconnaissance in
the Vietnam are you kidding me yeah that
didn't even make the cut for the colonel
yeah whatever you know I talked about
I'd put up a paragraph in a half a
paragraph you know yeah so he not only
did he power through it he went back
yeah and he did power through it by the
way yeah he didn't like no he didn't
yeah that part where he's talking about
don't let them laugh it you don't let
him laughing I like I underlined that
and highlighted it and then I put stars
by it cuz that's the kind of thing that
you think about like like do you know
the world sometimes seems like it's
having a joke with you yeah you know
like it's been like the joke is on you
you ever wake up you're like the joke is
on the joke's on me and everything
laughing at me that's everything like
that's not a good feeling right no let
that happen
no you don't and yeah thank you see even
keeping the sense of humor all this oh
yeah man such a humor laughing it was a
shitty situation never next time you
think about something being shitty now
you know what a shitty situation is we
all knew now we all now have a new
definition of what a shitty situation is
you still that's it that's the standard
and there that's it that's the standard
that's where you're at you know I know
well yeah so we're on the path like
there's no one's off the path anymore no
I can't you're not even allowed you know
I'm just on the path alright so when you
get when you start jujitsu if you have
it already which most of us have yeah
holy cow moose is a self oh yeah it's
like everyone that's thinking that's
still on the fence right just just get
over the fence because
every single person no I won't say every
single person there is a what percentage
I've heard feedback I think from a total
feedback of three people and it might
only be two that actually just didn't
like jiu-jitsu actually it's three one
female two males the one the one male I
went back and forth with for a while you
know he was like hitting me up on
Twitter this was pretty early on he's
like I just don't like I don't like
riding on me and and finally with that
guy he just didn't want to do it man
yeah and I was like look you know hey
cool you don't want to ruin your life
don't make this into a living hell
because you do something you do fully
hate it wasn't until the next guy that
bitterly complained that I was like
listen okay here's the point keep doing
it until you submit someone once you
submit someone you can stop yeah I
didn't think of that plan yet until the
guy number two and the other end was a
female that it was two things didn't
really like it but more important didn't
have anywhere to train and kind of just
got off the path but yeah so but that's
three out of many many many me I'm een
most people are like oh you know I'm
obsessed now I'm upset ya win or lose
like sometimes people will be like hey I
got beat up for hour now well everyone
says just went to my first jiu-jitsu
class got choked 28 times by a 14 year
old kid yeah I love it
yeah you know if you got your ego and
checked you say I love it you know God
sure you go and check your leg but you
know oh no this is for me I could punch
him try and punch him try and punch that
14 year old see what that triangle feels
like then you because it doesn't feel
good yes people though hard here at Dean
go hard on a triangle on you like
actually offensively he did a triangle
meet - yes he was just showing me
something he locked that triangle up so
tight I felt it in my lower back that
doesn't even make sense
they moved my spinal cord yeah yeah yeah
I don't done it for sure but alright so
we aren't doing jujitsu that's kind of
that's kind of a deal yeah so what Geeta
you get what rash guard do you get hey
look there's plenty jeez plenty rash
guards I'm not really all from origin
yeah there's only one well the good news
is and I was talking to some
folks at the muster about this few times
actually you know hey what geese should
I get they're still asking that question
well that's the thing they already know
the origin game Oh
now which one would you wanna get
whatever one you want more advanced
questions yeah because not the kind even
if you get that look you know how
there's like levels if you don't want to
call them that will say price point if
you will like the more expensive oil
it's not the kind of where you get that
and then you come in as a new wipe
everyone's like oh you're kind of
flossing hard with that that you know no
like if you get snot like in wrestling
if you wear gold shoes and rust yes
exactly it's not like that it's not like
that or you dye your hair or yes that's
a little statement that's a statement
yeah it's not like that right orange
hair yeah I'm really good yeah geez not
like that no no sir he's just to give
functional yeah man you know maybe you
know I don't obviously I don't go with
key in be lurker what are we doing this
this is particular so I don't know but
I'm assuming maybe it took more to make
certain ones or whatever but get to the
point is get whichever one you want
yeah straight up yeah lightweight heavy
weight whatever mm-hmm from origin main
dot com true true
also you got rash guards if you want a
rash guard that you can get a legit rash
guard you got t-shirts as well at from
origin so basic like clothing that's
what we're making right now at this time
denim yeah no I'm getting my I haven't
gotten my pair yet but yeah we're making
jeans so just be on standby it's gonna
take a little while to get that ramped
up but I saw a picture yeah oh yeah
that's already posted them yeah yeah so
we will be will be make because you know
why because everyone needs every human
wears jeans yeah because they're
functional you know so every human needs
jeans yeah and if everyone does then why
not get jeans that are made here made
with the highest quality all that stuff
anyways so yeah jeans are common we also
got some supplements yep Jocko
supplements so what joint warfare krill
oil discipline Mulk and worry kid milk
so what are these cover the most
important elements i think of slept
supplementation so joints those are
gonna go out on you that's a if you're
into lifting have you did you Jitsu hard
you into you work hard if you have like
a manual labor type job you know moving
company yeah I know I know you're a
mover I was American a bouncer a bouncer
that that wasn't very hard sometimes yes
on your like feet in these maybe
depending but I would say you know just
when you're I would say the workouts the
workouts get you joints I think
especially over time especially if
you're going very often and here's one
of the things about the joint stuff a
big part of it is you don't realize how
much the how much benefit there is to
taking krill oil and joint warfare on a
regular basis until you do it
yeah well into or until you stop oh yeah
big temperature I haven't stopped I
can't even answer that question but
you've told yes I have stopped yes
so yeah joint warfare krill oil
discipline which discipline like during
the muster I drink a lot of discipline
because like you know it's like go time
the whole time yeah so that's what now
I'll tell you we got something else
coming out we got discipline in little
pills go pills and I'll tell you why I
can't always pound a bunch of discipline
drink before let's say I'm going out to
speak sure I don't want to have to like
hit the head in the middle of the speech
because I drank like a bottle of water
right before I went out there
so anyways I was like hey can we make
these things in little pills and I can
take that can gonna get me yeah in the
rock and roll mode real quick so yeah
those comments not to mention you gotta
mix it up which isn't a big deal but if
you're on the good-good go yeah and you
know so yeah discipline go go pills
comments and they got a little bit of a
nootropic in them they got a little bit
of caffeine in them they've got a little
bit of go you know that's the main
ingredient the meeting greedy just go
hey also okay so as we know the warrior
kid milk is live and as we also know is
tasty it's live or it's live it was this
morning I was I was making some
strawberry mole
for the kids for me but it's the kids
mark and everyone at my house is
freaking going nuts
everyone in meiosis is drinking
strawberry more lame except for my
youngest daughter she's all about the
chocolate but somebody took the Molk
scoop from the ward and like they was
gone and this is what I realized there's
something going on because I I said to
my wife I said hey where's I said hey
where's the scoop for the for the
strawberry Quik I actually called it
strawberry Quik right because it tastes
yeah yeah you know but now I was talking
to Brian and Brian's got people are like
notifying him that they're getting like
the nostalgic memories of drinking
Nestle's Quik because that's where we're
at the strawberry one the chocolate one
doesn't taste as much like it tastes
delicious but it doesn't taste the same
like whatever like the quick like they
think exactly quick does because that
quick let's face it isn't really that
great but the strawberry Quik is great
our chocolate is probably better than
the Nestle's chocolate the strawberry
Quik is almost a replica and this is
illegal - for me to say this is like
comparing the no brands or something
like Mohammad okay all good and the
nostalgia part that is that is something
and I felt that you the apartment used
to get from the 7-eleven yeah this
strawberry Quik from the 7-eleven yeah
we got it from a store called big safe
on Kauai but yeah that's for you before
the protein and the regular milk that's
for the protein so so this is the other
thing I wanted to say is as soon as I
had the warrior kids strawberry milk I
texted Brian 14 seconds later and said
make adult you know milk strawberry so
it's in the works
[Music]
there's a couple that there's you can't
just say well I'll just double up
because there's a little bit more
protein in it in the you know when you
want to get a little bit more protein in
the adult milk yeah yeah that's nothing
for those of you that are freaking out
in the meantime take two scoops of two
scoops of warrior
kid Morgan you're still doing all right
yes you are also if you want to
represent the discipline equals freedom
way mmm
cuz this one does equal freedom I think
the more you grow up in life and embrace
the discipline you understand that more
cuz there are there are levels of
understanding to the core to the core
anyway if you want to represent go to
Jocko store.com
because dockwise a store which sure it's
on there please eating any second now
hoodies more of a winter hoodies winter
hoodies well Michigan hoodies if you're
in Iowa winter hoodies put Minnesota
potentially yeah kawaii their mainland
mainlander at least we're in the
mainland yeah we are in the mainland on
the main what about my people
probably yeah anyway the point is
there's a lot of cool stuff on there I
think it's cool def core difficult stuff
to the core all all things technically
are def core chemically true I'm gonna
leave it at that
also hats on there and women's stuff
also rash guards too and the the hats
are legit yeah shockers hats by the way
yes so those of you that are moral more
old-school in my opinion truckers hats
are more old-school that's what I wore
when I was a kid truckers hats yeah they
come in and out though you know they go
out then they come back no that's just
the urban wear oh you don't know about
style yes anyway flex it hats on there
as well a lot of good stuff if you want
something get something good way to
represent while staying on the path
there's some tea on the dock ot is on
there and various other things
anyway chuckle store.com yeah
and if you want to you can subscribe to
this podcast why do we even say this
well I guess okay if you're listening
right now and you've been listening for
three freaking about for I don't know
three and a half hours if you're if
you've done that go ahead and subscribe
cuz your your you definitely are part of
the team yeah thank you if you if you
haven't heard
if you haven't listened to this point
well then guess what you're not gonna
subscribe because you don't want to
subscribe so if you haven't subscribed
and you hear the sounds coming out of my
mouth right now go ahead and subscribe
iTunes Google Play stitcher and then
leave a little review action so we can
have a good time with it
also don't forget about there the
warrior kid podcast the warrior kid
podcast you can ask kids ask questions
to Uncle Jake and uncle Jake tells
stories about when he was a kid and
where he got his way from where he where
he uncovered the way also you got the
warrior Kid soap from Irish Oaks ranch
calm Aiden's up there he's taking
advantage of life yeah guess what you
got goats you're in California you can't
sell goat milk guess what you can do
make soap yeah that's what Aiden's doing
young Aiden you know I was watching
shark tank you know that show and you
know there's a kid on there doing his
thing
it was respect uh what was it some glue
okay some washable glue using it for
Legos which was kind of odd but I guess
if you're you know anyway long but I
thought it I thought about Aiden yeah
and the Jocko so here I see Aiden up
there with Jocko next julesberg good or
whatever you say all the time anyway
yeah good and while you're in the
subscribe mode then also subscribe to
the YouTube channel the Jocko podcast a
YouTube channel if you want to see
echoes videos which he puts all kinds of
time and effort into he's real super he
gets super things but crazy about it it
makes everything explode
sometimes reflecting off of things and
music cello music so that's on the
YouTube channel and we got some other
things planned for the YouTube channel
coming shortly coming quickly
we'll see I don't know quickly is really
a word that we used a lot back in Hawaii
but you know we'll do our best and we're
gonna we're making it happen and then
you got a psychological warfare
little-little
album with some tracks to kind of help
you push through some of those moments
of weakness where you're thinking you
just want to eat that doughnut you don't
need to know just don't need to and so
that'll help you out and we're also
making a second psychological warfare
album and if you want that then you can
if you want to if you want if you have a
special request for that should I do
some stop smoking cigarettes I've never
smoked cigarettes I think you should at
least yeah doing it and then if it's
like yeah cuz I would think but as far
as potential problems you might run into
like you know how like on the other ones
like you can I get you can relate so you
you know kind of what to say about it
you know like hey you're thinking this
or whatever yeah um yeah with the
smoking maybe you could compare it to
something maybe felt that you might be
addicted to in the past but I don't
think that's a whole that's a whole
different game ladies dogs like it's you
know yeah but I again I think it's a
different game to really like meet onsen
to be addicted to smoking I don't know
I've never smoked well yeah yeah that's
what that one's available wherever you
get mp3s
I Tunes Google Play also if you're on
the path working out this part of it and
write my four things working out was one
of them and you want to vary every
workout so this is where you get your
kettle bells on it uh-huh
come Tom it's called on it calm slash
jaco slash jock oh by the way get some
rings kettle bells a mace I'm you got it
the mace is dangerous if you don't know
what are you doing so yeah all the maces
seem like they're not heavy yeah and you
pick that thing up and you have a big
what's the big long thing with the ball
on the end called oh that's the mace
know I'm thinking about the club Club
bells yeah bells are way more dangerous
than the mace yeah and that's what I'm
saying where the club bells if you drop
a club bell on your toe you will lose
- yeah and the word that should be
called a toe remover yeah you are in a
hospital and you're like oh you got a
bad toe we're gonna have to remove it
okay cool come over here whack that
thing's gone yeah I like to workout
barefoot sometimes yeah and like you yes
a dangerous proposition
so yeah just be yeah and really I mean
us saying it it makes it sound like oh
like almost more dangerous than it
really uh my point is go on there and
look at the workouts first just cuz I've
never done it and I still have all my
toes yeah well never I've worked out
with it a bunch and they still have all
my toes so it's not that big of a deal
right but when you picked it up you're
like dang this is kind of having then
when you swing in you're like whoa whoa
whoa let me get the smaller one you know
well that's how I was anyway but anyway
you can get that stuff their rings are a
big deal in my opinion rings yeah
definitely you should have rings if you
don't have rings get them you see I said
in my opinion like I just know but they
even though you were preaching the rings
from day now I'm signed under the ring
housing a big stability muscles anyway
yeah I posted a picture of my son
I don't really post that many pictures
like my kids all the time like did
everyone small sure but he was lifting
you know when you lift and it's like he
just jumps in and says my attorney
doesn't deadlift they're pretty good
kids a good form by the way yes they do
so he does a deadlift on one of the
little on it Kendall knows the smaller
one z22 yeah and he's like watch me he
did was away 18 pounds how much does he
weigh I don't know 18 pound seems a
little light it was like he did it easy
laughter that's why I watch you weren't
you get him a bill he did start pushing
the envelope no and I'm just saying
that's what he did at that time and I
took a picture of it I'm not saying we
were maxing out me and my two year look
I'm maxing out deadlift and he only
could do 80 that's not what I'm saying
I'm saying anyway I took a picture of it
so you can see it okay and it's and it
has I looked at the future and that kind
of evaluate I was like this is a good
picture because it has like all the
Kettleman in a sense it's kind of
scattered about you frames it up well
technically I mean should be told I was
I'm making a video okay which may or may
not have warrior kid things
to it and so while I was doing I took
that picture
anyway it looks good on it was highly
represented in that picture and it let
me tell you this you know maybe if you
would give your kid some choco white tea
he would be able to deadlift more than
18 pounds he would might be able to
deadlift 8,000 pounds in fact there's an
actual guarantee because there's no aged
minimum requirement if you get that kid
on the jock a white tee there's the
eight thousand pound deadlift actually
my girl drinks - drinks legitimate
drinks of my wife's jakka white tee and
she deadlift at 8,000 there you go yeah
we later yes you know proven percent
kids everything chocolate white tea you
can get the cans which are ready to
drink or you can get the teabags that
you have to boil water too big oh god
I'm gonna boil water then you have to
seep you have to seep it
but then what when you in the morning I
don't drink Jocko white tea warm in the
morning every morning but there's
certain city like at the muster sure oh
I'm all about it and you know what a
seat means seat means you put the tea
bag in there and you let it sit for a
little while and for some people they
pull it out I just leave it in there the
whole time you know Alan Alan stages Oh
Ellen from mustard mustard Alan he
stages he stays like when I get up to
the podium it's staged so what's good
about that is it's in the morning time
you just have a little warm well guess
it's hot technically is hot but I drink
it warm yeah I'm with you I don't know
that there's a better beverage for that
little morning a little morning scenario
yeah this is a little morning's note so
a cup of dark a white tea so you can get
that also I've got some books I got the
way the warrior kid one end to end marks
mission it's one and two it's the same
series and those books I get more
incredible heartfelt
back on those two books then I could
have ever imagined and it's awesome
because kids can relate to the books and
it is great for the kids and it's great
for the parents too and I get parents
that just say this is making me a better
pair because it's all just a big it's
all just a cover and move right I'm
giving you this information here you get
to flank your kid because your kids
aren't gonna listen to you
not 100% that listen you a little bit
but they'll listen to someone that they
some some other person that seems like
kind of tough you know that they want to
listen to Uncle Jake yeah Uncle Jake
starts telling them what to do and
they're down totally dumb and yeah so
the warrior Kid books wanted to
obviously get one first mm-hmm because
it's a story and it kind of continues
you need to grow and it's gonna continue
to grow we're gonna see this we're gonna
see young mark all the way through
through high school yeah right
and yeah so those books will help kids
get on the path teach them about
discipline teach them about hard work
teach them about eating right teaching
about study habits teach them about
taking responsibility it's like
everything that a kid needs to know to
be quite honest with you well this is
and this it's kind of mean I guess in a
way
so I've worried kid to Mark's mission on
repeat in the household helps that for
my daughter's kindergarten they suggest
like all these things that you should do
every day and you can kind of choose one
and one is reading know for certain
amount of time so I just read one
chapter every single night every single
night as punishment
I won't though which is pretty rare
that's totally awesome though
yeah like if I see all threatened hey
hey no chapter tonight you know she
scrambles to you know fall in line
anyway um so the good thing about having
it on repeat because obviously we
finished or whatever I'm on around to
like towards the end of the book and she
just knows she knows that the answers
now you know she's still excited yeah
because of all now she knows so it's all
familiar you know so she kind of know
it's almost like now she's Jake five yes
I think she's yeah that's amazing yeah
that's amazing
so that's the way the warrior kid and
marksman get it for your kids get it for
your neighbor's kid
to get it for your kids across the
streets kids oh I'm sorry cuz why not
just help kids out yeah and it does help
whatever what I was about to say about I
feel bad cuz one night this is like two
nights ago she got this new unicorn book
kids book I don't know where she got it
from or something like this oh yeah from
their library or whatever you know part
of the book exciting new unicorn book I
read that thing the thing is so lame
it's a kindergarten level book by the
way and so I'm reading it and I'm
thinking this thing is lame I'm looking
at her she's over there playing with
LEGOs while I'm reading it Express she
disengaged so quit something yeah just
she was just off that get the word get
books background yeah uh discipline
equals freedom Field Manual this was
called the muster a lot of people this
this book definitely definitely hit
people hard yeah this point equals
freedom Field Manual so that book is it
good you know what this book is gonna be
good for Christmas I know it's only what
Thanksgiving Halloween Halloween yeah
but this book Christmastime this is the
book you get for the the person yeah you
know who you need it for those that
needs to get a little little help
getting on the path people read page a
day two pages a day I read it yeah I
wrote it and I read it because it keeps
you on the path so this Michals freedom
Field Manual then you got of course
extreme ownership which I wrote with my
brother life babban which is just
universally kind of become and accepted
as a as a as a book that you need to
read as a leader and that's followed up
by the dichotomy leadership which just
came out both those books New York Times
both sellers both those books number one
Wall Street Journal bestsellers both
those books continued to be on those
lists why because that's not through bit
the big advertising campaign mmm that's
just through word of mouth people get it
for themselves and they get it for their
teammate then they get it up the chain
of command down the chain of command get
your get your get your team in the game
with the dichotomy leadership and
extreme ownership and then we got miking
the Dragons which comes out November so
here's what it's about
Mikey young kid scared scared of
everything finds a book
the book that he finds it's called the
dragon Prince and he's scared to read it
because his pictures of scary dragons in
it but then he gets the courage to read
it cuz he sees a little boy in there too
that kind of looks like he knows what's
going on so he sees that little boy
because I'm gonna read it so he reads
the book and in the book the dragon
Prince there's the king is dead
and the boy is now the only one that
will defend the kingdom from the Dragons
that are over the hill in the dragon
cave and the boy is scared cuz he's only
seven years old and doesn't know what
he's gonna do goes and finds his
father's war chest pulls out the shield
pulls out the sword they're too big for
him and now he's even more scared but
then he sees a note in the bottom of the
war chest and he picks up the note and
here's what it says after he finds this
note it says to my son if you are
reading this now it means I am gone and
you are the one that must carry on our
kingdom is now what you must save and to
do that you have to be brave I know that
you think you don't know what to do but
remember that I was once a little boy -
I was also small and had fear in my
heart and I didn't even know where to
start
I couldn't imagine going over the hill
to face the dragons that wanted to kill
but don't worry son you will be just
fine if you can just keep these things
in your mind and then he goes on to
explain to him how he can overcome his
fear of the dragons and that's what this
the Prince does the Prince stands up to
his fears and faces the dragons and then
the boy Mikey learns from a lesson and
you know we have to remember that we all
have dragons to fight so and also
remember that this book is coming out on
Jocko publishing mmm why is that the big
publishers couldn't get it out in time
for kids to have it for Christmas and
that's what I once I had the book in my
mind I wanted kids to have it by
Christmas
and the big publishers couldn't make it
happen because they're big they're big
you know they got a lot of moving pieces
we're nimble over here you you know
we're nimble so since they couldn't get
it out in time I had to kind of like
they're a big dragon that's what they
are and so I had to kind of like stand
up to the dragons and we can stand up to
the dragons in our own right with this
with this book so if you want to help
fight the Dragons then grab a sword or
at least grab a copy and together we'll
slay the Dragons also we got national on
front leaders of consultancy that's what
we do we solve problems through
leadership it's me it's life it's JP
Dave Flynn Mike Cirelli and Mike bimah
don't call a speaking agency to get us
we won't do it
email s law in front or check the
website national on front comm or you
can email info national front calm the
muster we just got done with the muster
good show good show it's awesome awesome
to be up there awesome to meet all these
people coming from all over the world
South Africa New Zealand right it's
interesting just one woman came from New
Zealand and like didn't get a shout out
life was kind of name in some of the
countries where people from from and I
don't think well we didn't have it on
the list or whatever we should have done
a better job of screening it but she
came oh she's not come from New Zealand
I was like how that's awesome because
you guys didn't say it was like New
Zealand was represented strongly and I
signed a book she had to go up she had
to do a little like I think she did a
coin flip to figure out who gets to go
to the muster her or her husband she won
so I signed books for him so yeah come
to the monster with it the next one
there's going to be one in Chicago in
the spring and one in Denver in the fall
so looking like Australia in the winter
so down low but every every monster
we've done is sold out and these are
gonna sell out too so check extreme
ownership calm if you want to get into
that game of course now we also have EF
overwatch
big subject lots of people it's it's the
war on the war for talent that's what it
is yeah everyone needs good well if you
have a problem in your world what's
gonna solve that problem good leadership
where do you get good leaders from well
well we figured out is we get good
leadership from the military so we got
Special Operations and combat aviators
that are ready to go out and do work and
we're putting them into companies that
need leaders so if you got a company or
if you're a vet spec ops or combat
aviation go to EF overwatch and you can
get in the game there and if you want to
continue this conversation that we're
kind of having right now you know it's
been kind of a long conversation but if
you want to keep it going so you can
find us on the interwebs on Twitter on
Instagram and on Facebook EKKO is that
EKKO Charles and I am at Jocko willing
and thanks to all of you for making this
podcast possible by all of you I mean
first of all the military who protects
our way of life and who sacrifice so
much for our freedom and our security
and here at home police law enforcement
firefighters paramedics EMTs
correctional officers border patrols
first responders you know who you are
those of you in uniform thank you for
your service in protecting us here at
home and everyone that listens wherever
you are and whatever it is that you do
teachers investment bankers plumbers
engineers electricians doctors and
nurses and builders and bricklayers and
everyone else that is out there making
their way like I said earlier it can get
hard sometimes that's the way life is
and sometimes you can actually hear life
laughing at you sometimes but I say
don't let it it's like when the Chinese
guards conducted a mock execution on
Colonel Richardson and the other
prisoners
that he was there with and then the good
the guards they stood there and they
were laughing they were laughing at
these terrified prisoners and only
didn't like that at the time the Master
Sergeant he didn't like that so he
yelled he yelled get up
don't let them laugh at you get up and I
recommend that if you feel like the
world is laughing at you you do the same
you get up and get after it and until
next time this is echo and Jocko